All right.
And we are
back.
There we go.
Okay.
Okay, there we go. Lovely.
Yep, here we go. We're good. I have
chat.
All is well. Okay, so I am building
this.
Oh no. Oh no. You can't hear anything.
Oh god. Ooh,
what did I screw up?
Um, video capture device
audio input.
Yes, I can see I can see chat now. Uh,
okay. You hear me? Okay.
I think I'm doing something right here.
I Yeah. Yeah, it was definitely the
voice was showing up in my
in my
uh
when I was testing out and hearing a
recording. So, I think it's all working
good. Uh I might do deck reviews at some
point uh on stream. That is not what I'm
doing today. I'm just uh uh I I have
this deck I need to to workshop a little
bit and I figure I will just do a little
bit of that. Um
though I think uh I I'll probably stream
some more uh MTGO gameplay probably
tomorrow.
Um
so that should be cool and fun. I want
to get like a clip of that uh streamed
and recorded for my second channel.
Wonderful.
So,
what I'm kind of trying to do here is,
uh, yeah, card suggestions are all good.
What I'm kind of trying to do here is
this is a Catilda deck. Uh, I'm trying
to keep it very, very low budget. So,
I'm going within kind of the
excluding basic lands constraint here.
Um, $25ish.
Uh, trying to keep it under that. And
I'm trying to see how much flicker I can
integrate. I think a lot of the flicker
is a little bit expensive, but I'm fine
if I think the flicker is probably going
to be the most expensive part of the
deck, but I think that's that's that's
fine. Um,
Contour's Cloud is definitely worth it
for this sort of uh deck.
Um,
but yeah, I think this is kind of like a
white riff on Rada. I I find that
there's just a ton of really good ETB
white creatures um that can kind of
pivot into some some later game
nonsense. So, I think with like Reverend
Hoplight is pretty awesome with uh
Katilda, you get you get some pretty
current quantity of cheap humans. I am
this is I I am opting for a higher curve
Katilda deck.
Uh, Felia Felia is kind of on the line.
Like you can you can I can fit a $2 card
if it's like really good. Like I'm
running Conjur's Closet currently.
That's two bucks 50, but I think that's
just so so good that it's it's probably
worth it.
Um, but yeah, just I'm just trying to
tweak this deck and get some more filter
uh get some more flicker into it. Um, I
know the kind of there's several kind of
flicker return to end of turn cards.
that I think are pretty solid. Um, those
can also be board wipe dodges. Uh, and
if I add more board wipes to the deck,
those can be kind, you know, I can I can
turn something into a one-sided board
wipe effectively. So, I think there's a
lot of potential value there. Um,
I think Tree Shaker Chimera isn't all
that good as as draw goes. So, I might
give that a
cut for now.
Yeah, Far Traveler is decent. I'm just
that that one is is very cheap. It it is
a, you know, very money cheap flicker
engine. Uh so I think in that way it's
tempting for sure. Um I just don't know
if the restrictions are too intense on
it. Like obviously it needs commander
out. Uh which Catilda is definitely
going to be a target for removal some
games. Um if I get like a bunch of
humans out off of something.
So uh I I have I have the full maybe
board kind of off to the side here
categorized. Um, so th those are just
going to be all of the cards along the
right side that are kind of separated
uh with with that that little bit are
going to be cards that I have considered
but which are not in currently. So it's
kind of kind of a
kind of a long list. I probably need to
prune these so that the page isn't, you
know, 10 miles tall.
Um, whisper angel's not probably a good
enough card here.
Austere command is already something
I've decided that I probably need
because that's just it's just so good.
Um, if I can hit lowcost creatures plus
enchantments or or etc and such like um,
Guardian Faith is good. How much How
much is it these days? It doesn't It
does not trigger my flickers though,
which is the one thing that's kind of uh
making me not want to put a whole lot of
money into it.
Uh I cards that get a bunch of humans
are pretty decent acceleration, but um
yeah, we'll throw that in removal.
Yeah, cards that create humans are
decent acceleration. Although I I'm
I'm kind of wanting to do some amount
of, you know, either ETB lands or
uh kind of router style stuff. Although,
honestly, drum hunter is not going to be
good enough. I don't think I I don't I
do not like drum hunter here. Think
we're going to going to cut that.
Torrance is interesting. Um,
I feel like in some ways it feels a
little like win more here just because
uh it'll scale up to a lot of mana
eventually, but this deck isn't fast
enough where it's going to be getting
impact immediately and I'm kind of
worried that it's going to like lead
into a wipe or lead into Katilda getting
hated out.
Um, I am not digging Tree Shaker
Chimera.
It's not a bad card. I just feel like
there's got to be better draw here.
Genesis Storm was one I really wanted to
add. Um, this is one I've considered for
Rada, but I think the the fact that a
lot of the creatures are Cascade makes
me a little hesitant here. There is both
less Cascade and I think the commander
is going to be more of a target for
removal. So I
call this later acceleration.
See sorcery.
I don't know that I need to be
categorizing the card type, but you
know, whatever. It seems fine enough.
Um I don't know if I want Stone Cedar
Hero. It's definitely decent though.
It's a very very decent card.
Cultivator Colossus.
I I am not doing deck reviews today.
This is a This is one of my my decks
that I am tuning, but I I'll probably
stream some deck reviews at some point
in the coming weeks because that's
that's a fun thing to do.
Uh,
I am not I'm not really feeling
Thunderfoot Velociere. I think this deck
is a little bit slower than the Rada
deck.
Vizier of Deferment.
I have not heard of that.
Or have I?
Is that what uh
No, that's Angel of Condemnation.
Deferment.
Exile target creature if attacked or
blocked this turn.
Interesting.
Okay.
I think I'm mostly trying to avoid the
one-time flickers. I just think I can
get more value than that. So,
but that's it's it's definitely
interesting because at a certain point
you can start putting in those onetime
flickers and then if you flicker your
board then suddenly, you know, it turns
into extra flickers. Um,
uh, the deck should be linked in the
comments or in the in the description.
Um, it is a
it is a Catilda deck that is kind of a
uh rather a battle cruiser type thing. I
I don't know that this is going to be a
workable list quite yet, but um I am
just going to see where it ends up if I
if I end up feeling like it's got a lot
of potential.
That's kind of what I'm trying to do
here. Um
yes, I think this card is not quite what
this deck is looking for. um
just because
it's it's it's kind of a more aggressive
card. I mean, I guess it's good if I get
a bunch of humans. I don't how much
token creation do I have currently?
Creature token.
Yeah, Alex budget the build is
definitely good. So, I have some
creature tokens. I I these are on the
chopping block so I don't even know
about those. So I have like these
four basically which are nice but it's
not that much.
You don't have
um I I haven't really felt the need to
have haste in the rotted deck. It's very
much like a I find it kind of fun to to
give to play a bunch of and
then give people a turn to to prepare.
It's one of those things where I'm sure
you could make the deck more effective
at killing people, but I I think it's
it's perfectly fine to have it just kind
of uh not be super super fast.
Livio, what does Livio do?
Livia Oaths. Oh, okay. Okay. Yeah,
that's a seems like an interesting
commander.
So, this deck is going to be serving a
somewhat different purpose. Um,
if it ends up being the deck I choose
for this, uh, it's it's going to be very
very budget, so I need to trim down on
kind of any of the higher costed value
engines and stuff. Um, no, uh, you know,
no kind of case of the locked hot house,
no beast whisperer. I'm going to be
missing a lot of kind of the the draw
engines there. I think the addition of
white also allows the deck to pivot in a
more controlling direction. Um, so
that is going to be
cool. There's just so much flicker you
get and there's so many like white
creatures with disgusting ETBs. Like if
you flicker an Angel of the Ruins, like
I I already know that's gross from my my
shroom deck. Um, but yeah, there's just
a lot of gross things you can do with
with white. Also, I wasn't familiar with
this card. This this card's pretty
sweet.
Had not seen that before. That is pretty
cool. Honestly,
a lot of these are are are kind of like
Angel of the Ruins and Protector of the
Wastes are are both kind of making my my
Terrason look a little sad. like it's
not a bad card, but it it it's it's
there's a good chance it's going to end
up getting cut just because there is so
much better removal out there.
Um, so so this this isn't going to be uh
a deck I have in my normal uh pool of
decks. I just wanted to build a uh a
budget deck for a specific sort of
budget deck purpose and just trying out
a version of this. I also might look at
some other options. I just want like a
very kind of slower grindy deck. And
this seemed like an interesting thing to
explore a little bit just to see whether
it would end up turning out interesting.
Um I don't know if Sata is what I want
in this deck.
Zopa is very good. It's It's just like a
very solid stabilizer threat. Rampaging
Yaquai. Oh yeah, that's a that's a card.
How useful that. There we go.
Yeah, definitely a decent card. Although
it it doesn't work with flicker is my
concern. Like I guess it can mess up a
bunch of like little rocks.
Yeah, honestly I think uh I I excluded
up the beantock from Rata because I I
wanted to keep the gimmick of nothing
below four mana. I just find that really
fun. Um I also just don't think I need
it. There's there's plenty of good value
engines. Um, but in this case, I'm I'm
trying to optimize a little bit more on
a budget. So,
I think uh of the Beantock makes more
sense here. Although, I could still see
it being worse than like some like ETB
stuff. I don't know. I have not fully
looked. I do need an eternal witness in
here. That is that is one thing I I do
need. Um cuz that if I run eternal
witness the all of the like semester's
end ghost way style cards become so much
better.
Yeah. So let's let's get let's get an
Eternal Witness in here. Let's get our
our mass flicker cards in here and then
we'll see where we're at. So I'm going
to throw this under. Is it really a
dollar?
Yeah. Makes sense.
Yeah.
So, I'm going to throw that under value.
Value. Draw. Sure. Draw.
Toss up. Titan of Industry. Titan of
Industry is decent. That's one of the
ones I'm guessing I'm probably not going
to spend big on uh
the removal of the deck just because
there's there's a lot of like flicker
and draw that is a little bit more
expensive. But um yeah, I I have I have
this kind of category of various uh ETB
creatures. Um Overworld Hydra honestly
kind of sucks. So that's that's not
going to be what I'm looking for here.
mostly because this is a budget deck
that's just not going to have decent
lands. Um,
Thorn Mammoth and Koga are ones that are
a bit more likely to make it in.
Timeless Witness is not bad either.
Timeless Witness is definitely one I
would consider for sure. Um, and I could
I could see it just being the case that
more copies I guess it it it is also a
human, so that's probably worth just
popping in right now.
Yeah. So, let's let's get Timeless
Witness in there.
Um, because yeah, I think if I can start
doing the the Eternal Witness uh flicker
value loops, that that that I feel like
is a good play pattern to start striving
for if I'm looking for this to be like a
really gross later game grindy deck.
Yeah. So, let's get this in here.
Um, I definitely have some kind of jank
flicker in right now. So yeah, mainboard
flicker category.
I need to hit up the architect people
and ask them if they can differentiate
mainboard and maybe board categories.
I love making feature requests
on bushwack. Bushwrack is decent.
I think my land count is high enough
where I don't feel the need for
bushwack. I guess I could like cut a
land and have a bushwack in here, but um
I would rather just run keep keep the
high land count and then go from there.
I'm running Eagles of the North, which
is kind of similar to a bushwack. But
I think that one feels a bit better
because it also has an ETB.
All right, let's get Lazel acrobatics in
here. I think this card is lovely. Like
it a lot. Um,
and then Ghost Ways, I think, a little
bit more expensive and also it's it's
not really worse, I guess, cuz I don't
really have one- one counters in this
deck, I don't think. I should double
check that for sure.
Parting gust. Parting gust is decent.
Yeah, I I would definitely consider
that. Um I should add that to my
add that to my main board and we'll take
a look at it in a bit.
Um, I was also considering some other
really jank uh flicker like mirror of
life track trapping is flicker
in the sense that it you know can have a
creature enter twice.
It also flickers for my opponents. I
don't know if that matters. I wonder I
wonder how many hydra decks you would
nail with this or like other decks that
have some sort of like thing that goes
on a creature based on the casting.
I even know I I have no sense of how
good that would be honestly. Um
that's a that's a really interesting
card. Like the the the the super cheap
cost is is interesting.
Um
Eternal Dragon. I like Eternal Dragon. I
don't know if this is the deck for it.
Uh,
Fierce Empath was one I was definitely
considering. I think woodland bellowware
is
like two something. So, it's 254. It's
It's not bad. It's It's a very good
Yeah, it's not No, no Cast Claws. And I
am running a handful of
I am running a handful of three drops.
Yeah, it grabs Ewit. Ooh.
Okay. Okay. Hold on here. That's That's
really good. Okay. Yeah, because if I
get it's only green creatures, so it
would have to be Ewit or
I'm probably not adding Champion of
Lambhole. I don't think it's worth the
budget. Uh but if I added Fierce Empath
along with Woodland Bellware,
uh maybe maybe pop torren back in. Um I
think that could become really good.
That's that's kind of interesting.
[Music]
Yeah, that's that's pretty interesting.
Uh, is there a way to see his full list
as you're editing? Uh, yeah. I mean, it
um I think I have the list linked. I
don't I don't know where YouTube stream
show descriptions. Um, but if if not
that I it's also on my architect
profile. I just made it public, I think.
So,
yeah.
Yanick. What is Yanick? This card sounds
familiar.
Oh, sure, sure, sure, sure. Yeah,
definitely.
Uh, so I think the great Aurora is just
good in a big mana deck. um like you
know anytime some if you're building up
and somebody else is trying to kind of
put together a big board put throwing
down the great Aurora I think throws a
mention that pretty good although I
might swap it out for a different board
wipe I think cuz I I'm kind of
considering it a board wipe here um
because it you know if I'm behind on
board my opponents are head on board
it's going to kind of reset that
probably give me the upper hand since I
have a bunch of lands out presumably if
my ramping went well I I don't have a
sense of how, you know, consistent this
deck will be compared to the Rada deck.
But that one I might swap out for
for a better board wipe. Not a better
board wipe, but like a more like board
wipey board wipe. I do think cleansing
Nova wants to be in here.
Yes, we'll have to see about that. Okay,
so I was adding Yeah, I was going to add
ghost way. I think there's a$120
printing of this.
So, is it that?
Sure. We'll we'll take dollar8. So,
that's going to go in.
So, we're going to pop these in and then
I just want to see if we can get the
budget back down to a manageable level.
Flicker instant. Sure.
Okay. So, right now we are at 105 cards.
$29 budget. So, we got a fair amount to
cut.
Um,
some of these I think are just kind of
bad. Like I I can't tell how good Gil
Rein is.
It's probably good enough.
It's definitely definitely a little bit
clunky.
Do you have enough type variety? Uh,
that's actually a good point. There's
probably less type variety here than in
some decks.
See, where do I see that? Uh,
quantity of subtypes.
Human. No, you're right. You're right.
You're right. I
Yeah, four angels. Like, there's there's
definitely some amount of variety here.
Um, but yeah, I think 13 humans out of
how many current creatures? I don't
actually have a sense of how many
creatures I'm running in this. I want to
say like 35ish.
41 41. Okay. Yeah,
I can see bad gas working out there
having temple the false gods to to then
fetch with so me spawn plus two mana
acceler
um temple the false gods.
Temple of false gods is a card I usually
hate. I think in higher land count decks
it's more forgivable.
Uh,
so that could be interesting.
Sewing micros.
Actually, I haven't considered sewing
micros. I mean, it's a little bit of a
non-bo with flickers. Yeah, it's also
$2,
unfortunate.
Okay, so we need to cut a little bit of
budget from this. Are there any lands
that don't really need to be here? I
think I was going to do like a caves
package like I did before. Let me make
sure I'm not like breaking the bank with
my caves package.
25.
Yeah. None of these capes seem too bad.
They're all like very cheap.
Yeah,
wave of vitriol would be something for
sure. Uh although I think I would I
think I would just prefer to run an
actual board wipe rather than wave of
vitriol run like an hour of rev or clean
cleansing nova but it's a very funny
card. I I would
um
I
expect that this deck would be playing
against other very cheap decks. So, Wave
of Vitriel is probably less good uh
since there's fewer land options, more
basics in decks, etc.
True. I can't I can't sort by sort by
price. That is definitely Stonehorn
Dignitary is interesting. That's
definitely one I might consider. Um
I have like a kind of stabilization
category here for like some life gain.
Um Verdon's avatar is great.
The rest of these I don't know. Baird
honestly is kind of mid. I mostly just
included him because he's a four cost
human.
Um yeah people love their Apex
Altasaurus.
It's a it's a it's a fun card. I think I
ran in my Glya deck a while back
but okay. Yeah. Uh somebody mentioned
sorting by price which is a good call.
What do we got? Yeah. Con closet for
sure.
Ewit. Yeah.
Do I need beans? Do I need beans? Do I
need beans? I don't know if I need beans
or not. Um
I also don't know how I feel. Is there
predation? I definitely would consider
that. That was one that I had in for a
bit, bumped back to the the kind of
maybe board. Might might bring it back
in.
But how do we how do we cut a little bit
of budget from this? I don't know if I
want rampaging or not. I don't know if
this is a deck that wants that. I'm
going to bump this for now. We might see
about it later if we want more more beat
down potential. Um, but yeah, I'm going
to go ahead and bump this to
my my maybe board
market festival and Dawn's Reflection. I
I don't trust
enchantment ramp. Um,
I like if I'm paying for mana for ramp,
I kind of want it to be lands. Um,
I there could be some exceptions to
that, but I What?
Come on.
Did I not
did I not cut you? Yeah. There.
Um,
I think Drew of Purification. I I think
one I should probably cut here. It's a
great great great great card.
Uh, building this for
$25 deck reasons. Um, is definitely not
going to enter my kind of main pool of
decks if it does end up being the thing
I build. Um, but yeah, I just want to
play around with it. See how it works in
white. See how cheap I can get it. And
that will be kind of what's going on.
Planer guide. What is a planer guide?
Remove planer.
[Laughter]
What is that card?
Oh.
That is fascinating. Okay. Yeah, it's a
creature that that's
it's it's budget flicker.
That's interesting. Um
can't can't be looped with uh e-wit, so
a little bit worse, but I still kind of
fun. I like it.
Yeah. My my thing with I kind of want to
cut beans for now. I don't
uh do I want beans?
Um how many decks have I made? I a lot.
Like if I go to my uh
I think like
yeah I think like twothirds of that is
stuff that wasn't public maybe three
quarters. So
return from exile card.
Dragon scale. Yeah, dragon scale general
is decent. I just don't know if this is
deck is fast enough to want that. Um,
like I'm really looking to to grind and
put on some some control hate in late
game. What is disorienting choice
for each opponent? Choose a
Oh, okay. Yeah. So, it's like a a riff
on
um
Yeah, it's a riff on
like the the the
offer the
tempt with discovery. It's like kind of
a riff on that. I that's
I
so if I'm giving my opponent choices, I
want the amount of total value the card
produces to be I think higher than this.
Um like how often is it just three
lands?
I don't know. like the opponent has to
have an artifact enchantment which is
decently likely but if they don't this
is a explosive vegetation at best
because they they do entertapped.
It is any land but u this is a budget
deck so there's not a whole lot there.
It's interesting though. It's
interesting.
Uh
yeah,
dude of purification is a human. That is
so true. I hate it.
Yeah, I know. I want the beans.
The the beans is good.
Rift sweeper.
Oh,
interesting. Interesting.
Yeah. So, I'm trying to think.
If Beans is drawing one card a turn, I'm
pretty happy. Um, if I play it early, it
might not do that immediately, but any
turn after like
five, it should be drawing at least one
card a turn. Um, and then late enough,
uh, or if I get like a big burst of
humans out with something like the
flashback human generator card.
Um,
where is it?
Uh, increasing devotion. If I get
increasing devotion, I can theoretically
get beans pretty early.
Time of need. Do I have legendary? I do
have Thalas Lancers for tutoring for
legendaries because that is definitely a
lovely thing. I'm trying to think if I
have other legendaries that I'm like
really really wanting here.
also
containment priest.
Rampage of the clans is one I've
considered. Although I feel like
unironically I feel like if somebody has
a bunch of like little artifacts and
enchantments, they can kind of just
steamroll.
I don't know. It's a little spooky. I
feel like you need followup for it and I
would rather just pay, you know, six
mana for an actual like I can just run
cleansing nova instead and that's just
like one more mana. You don't have to
worry about getting
trampled down by a bunch of three three
centaurs. That card is horrifying. I
think that the the bears one is a little
bit better like because that one I think
gives a bear to each player who
lost a thing and that's that's a little
bit better.
Uh yeah. Yeah, it's it's it's ramp
having having five drops on turn four to
five should be pretty consistent, I
think. Um
so that
Hanukkah ranger
in principle beans is quite good. I I'm
just trying to figure out how to fit in
the stuff I want to fit in Ranger.
Yeah, that's like a like a a little baby
little baby thorn mammoth.
Um, yes. I'm trying to cut price a
little bit. I I almost want to cut
what what what's what's too expensive in
my lands because I think right now I'm
spending
h spending $3 on lands. That's not too
bad.
It's not terrible terrible.
Um,
yes. So, I cut out a couple of high
drops.
2843.
Yeah, d of purification's really good.
Big old generous scent.
Yeah, generous scent is solid. I had it
in for a bit. Um, but it's like 40 cents
and
I don't know. I I I don't even feel like
land cycling is that good in this deck.
There's just a lot of lands and mostly
sorcery speed plays.
Fortune, I don't know. Fortune. Um, so
part of my issue with Felia is just that
I don't fully trust it to be able to
swing in consistently. Um, Fortune I
think has some of the same issue.
I know. Yeah. The fact that this this
manavase is is $3 is pretty sweet. I
think the temples were like, you know, a
buck 50 when they were printed back in
Theos. So,
it's definitely nice to be able to
throw together a manabase that is this
low cost.
Congregation at Dawn. I that one that
one puts on top of library, right?
There's like three cards on top of
library.
I I don't know if that Yeah, three cards
reveal shuffle and put on top in any
order.
Then then shuffle and put those cards on
top in any order. Yeah, that's I mean
it's it's like two bucks and I don't
know that I like kind of a a value
negative sort of thing.
There are definitely a lot of mana. I
should just make a an eight plus mana
category in my maybe board because there
are definitely
uh
there are a lot of just like kind of
eight or more cost cards that are that
are kind of goofy.
I don't know that I'm really feeling um
great Aurora at the moment. I'm going to
toss that there.
We can maybe think about it later.
I
I really don't know how I feel about
Abdel Adrian, honestly. Um or like
there's a similar angel that that also
like exels any number of things you
control. I
I think my hesitation with those is just
that I don't I really want to be able to
flicker the Abdaladrian to get them back
immediately.
um or to get some immediate value out.
Like if they go if they go under, pop
back out, get a bunch of ETBs, go back
under again, I think that's fine. Um
but
broken. Isn't broken the one that lets
you put a land from your hand into play?
Think of a different one. Yeah. Yeah.
card's okay, but I
it's it's kind of tricky because it's
low cost removal, but it's clearly
intended for decks that run a lot of
lands, which is not
not a super common niche in commander.
Forell Angel is good.
Yeah, there there are definitely some
number of those effects. Um, yeah,
there's there's yeah, like I I made a I
made a Torston deck that had a whole
bunch of those and that definitely
that works. It works when you hit like a
critical mass of them or if you have
like the little cheap flickers. Uh, I
just I I feel I feel a little bit
spooked putting them into a higher cost
deck. I think
bag of tricks.
Um, this this is the same land count as
Rada, I think. Um,
like 41 works pretty well for decks
where you want to be hitting your land
drops every turn religiously. Um, and it
also it also kind of works fine if
you're running a bunch of land ramp
because you get deck thinned over time.
Roll a da real on top of your library
creature card with mana value equal to
the result. Uh, that that'll whiff on
some number of those. Like I guess I
could I could I could put in like a one
drop and a two drop and whatnot, but I
don't really feel the need.
41 is also
uh 40 41 I think works out okay as long
as you have enough like draw and as long
as you have enough stuff to dig through
your deck. Um I am a little worried
about the draw here. In fact, I
God, how how hard would it be to fit in
the
fierce empath woodland? Woodland Bellar
is 254. I want that to be less.
I like the card so much. Uh because
that's that's really lovely to have as
like
uh kind of a filter. Uh,
it's almost like filtering because it it
can find Eternal Witness and it can find
Fierce Empath if I were to add it. Uh,
it's just
this deck is struggling on budget
because of the the the flicker cards all
being kind of pricey. Um, I could cut
the Eternal Wonder. I don't know.
It seems like one of the worst flicker
options.
I am I'm drinking a a a
energy drink I bought at Costco.
It is It is lemon and raspberry. It's
pretty tasty. Uh yeah, another round I
think seems pretty solid to me. It's a
little awkward that it's sorcery for
you, but it just it just seems so
potentially disgusting.
Um,
Rachel Weeks,
hey Rachel, uh, have you looked at
Disciple of Kis Nin? that card. I think
this is trying to be a big mana deck.
That is like almost like a counter to
big mana, but that card is very funny. I
I love Disciple of Kais N. I I've never
found a place to play it, but uh it's
it's such a fun card,
I think.
So, I think um
yeah, I want to say there was there was
a Costco in my area that had some some
Final Fantasy stuff. Uh but
that I I don't know. I even at a cheap
price, I don't really feel the need.
Oh, I'm I'm sure Elk can can convince me
to to fit with the Bellawa in.
Keeper of Fables is pretty decent. If
I'm
if I'm really trying to drop the budget
of the draw suite, then I think that
becomes decent.
Um,
that's not amazing though.
Keeper of Fables. We'll toss that in
there. It's worth worth considering at
least. Um, man, the fact that Mangara is
so cheap these days is nice. I think
that's got to stay in.
You consider Bramble Familiar. Is that
the one? I know it's a seven drop on the
creature. I don't remember what the
other effect does. Or no, it's it's
seven mana for the the adventure. That's
right. Yeah, I it's I just don't need
early ramp because I have I have
Catilda.
like the car can flicker and the car can
also uh be removal. It's it's a funny
card. I think I'm also running like I
was maybe going to add uh yeah, I was
actually looking at
Kerodora because there are some decent
vehicles to grab and a couple that are
flicker things. So like uh golden arguy
flickers. Um if I were to add the
there's like that other one that
flickers um that somebody mentioned a
little while back. Although
I don't know that that one's that one's
not all that tempting to me. But but
yeah uh Kerodora could grab limousine
Argusy. Let me see.
It just those two. Yeah. I'm I don't
think I have any mounts in this deck.
Yeah. No, no mounts.
Perhel is funny. Um I don't want to run
too many like big dumb guys though. And
I feel like Zulpa has already taken up a
big dumb guy slot if that makes sense.
Like
Uh, parting gust. That one does seem
pretty decent. I would definitely
consider that. Um,
yeah, that seems good enough for sure.
We'll toss that in. Yeah, because it's
it can be a flicker, it can be uh
removal, and if I like I don't have that
much cascade in the stack, but if I do
cascade into it, there there are ways
around that. So, that seems pretty
solid.
Voice of many. Voice of many. That's
like draw a card for each opponent who
has fewer creatures than you.
I
don't I I I don't
I could see it, but I don't like that
it's conditional. I think I can do
better than that.
Parhelion over to Zulpa. Let me see. Is
Paralian need money?
Legitimately I'm I'm getting kind of
tight on budget. Yeah, Parhelion. Let's
see. Parhelion.
Parhelion II. Yeah, I I don't feel like
cuz one of the things that makes me like
Zulpa is just that it's, you know, been
thrown in so many precons that it's a 16
cent card. Parhelion's closer to a buck
and I that's that's I don't want to be
spending a buck on my big dumb guys.
Uh, pick your pick your poison is is a
solid card. I don't think I need it here
though.
Um really I want like I I definitely I I
definitely am seeing the appeal of Voice
of Many just because I think it does fit
a nice niche of being ETB draw at a kind
of middling mana cost. If I could if it
literally just read draw two cards or
you know draw.
Yeah, if it just read draw two cards
then I think I would like it a lot. You
know, I don't even need the three cards
off of it. But I think the fact that it
is not consistent is a little bit
worrisome. Emergent woodworm is actually
decent and that does do some things with
flicker. So I could definitely try that.
I mean it kind of does like it
you scoop off the one one counters but
also like the they it's it's you know
scoop off the one one counters but you
get another trigger of the backup which
I think is probably the bigger deal.
I'm seeing
is emerging wood actually almost a
dollar. I can see
I know I I I specifically called that
card out as one I like. Yeah. Okay.
That's that's that's that's
a bit that's funny.
Lenor Tribe. Is that the one that's like
a I No, I think that one's like a like a
$5 card, right?
H. Not quite. No, no, no. It's it's it's
budget. Um,
it's not bad. I think I'd rather have
like a I think I'd rather take an
explosive vegetation over it, though.
That's just that just seems a little bit
better
because three mana I I will have three
mana plays to weave in sometimes, but
not super super often.
Great Oak Guardian, the one that untaps
things. I don't know that that's going
to be doing all that much for me here.
Let's see.
Cheaper printing of sunb blast angel.
Probably not.
I saved ascent.
cents.
I definitely do need to to crunch the
budget here a little bit.
Honestly though, is this card good?
It serves like a recursion purpose, I
think, is is kind of nice. Um, see if
this is a cheaper printing, so I don't
need to think about it.
92 cents
73 cents. I'm inclined to leave this out
for the moment and try it again
in a bit cuz that's just
it's just it's just worse.
It's just it's it's not meaningfully
better than something like Luminina
Primordial. That's a 25cent card. You I
think it has some utility bringing back
things from the graveyard. Uh yes,
philosophy is very similar with Rata,
although this deck is looking to be a
little bit grindier, a little bit more
controlling. Um
red really doesn't have that many
options for containing later game
threats among its high-cost cards. Um
like you know all all the all the good
removal is like low cost all the good
instance speed removal I should say is
kind of low cost uh stuff.
Woodland acolyte that's the one that uh
the adventure one
I think the right one. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
Put target permanent card from a
graveyard on top your library. That's
that's it's a decent card.
Put in the reward.
Yeah. Yeah. I
fit Angel of Ruin into your budget.
Is there a different one?
The world spell.
Uh yeah, I I've been using Architect for
a while and I've just never felt the
need to swap over. Um
Moxfield I I don't love the UI. I kind
of like the the layout on Architect. I
know there are kind of options. Moxfield
definitely has a lot of options for
tweaking the the UI to be more to your
preference, which is, you know, cool for
it, I guess. But uh that's
look at the top seven cards your library
reveal a non-saga permanent card from
among
I
it's decent. It doesn't
I feel like if I play this out it gets
one trigger and then it gets rocked by a
removal spell. I'm going to be feeling
pretty bad. And if and if you're ever
reading ahead, this card is just kind of
not great. Like I guess it's fine if you
like read ahead to three,
you know, crap out a couple things for
seven mana, but that's
seems
how much banding how much banding was I
including? Probably not a lot. Uh this
is a this is kind of a battle cruiser
deck built around Katilda. It's doing a
somewhat similar thing to Rada where
it's it's got some kind of turn three
ramp that that speeds it up. But uh I'm
am doing I'm trying to introduce a
pretty robust flicker game plan.
Although the the budget is is fighting
with me a little bit. So, we got to we
got to do some some cuts.
Uh, protection is somewhat important,
but I I what I like is that uh cards
like Lazelle's Acrobatics and Ghost Way
uh already do a protection purpose. Like
you can do that in response to a removal
spell. Um, kind of similar with like uh
parting gust and
pegasus guardian.
Any any flicker lets you dodge removal
to some extent.
So, this deck definitely plays more at
instant speed than the the rotted deck
did.
Let's see what what can I cut for
budget.
Yeah, if I can get this back down to
budget, I might start considering if uh
if the woodland bellware fierce empath
package works because I think that's
that's really tempting if I can make it
happen. Um it's just rough that the card
is two bucks 50. That's
[Music]
cuz that that's worth like several
premium draw spells.
Cataclysmic Gearhulk is one I would
consider. Eerie Interlude is the one of
those effects that's out of budget. Um
the rest are around a dollar which is
workable.
Uh Genesis Storm I think just works like
the cards in here are pretty high
costed. So if I Genesis Storm I'm going
to be getting you know on average
10 mana worth of stuff if I've cast my
commander once. And then I also am
imagining that there will be some games
where Katilda eats a lot of removal um
because it is a much better manador than
than Rada because if I get some humans
out it it can pop off. So in those games
it can serve as kind of a really good
recovery spell where if I've been having
a bad game I play the
I play the the
uh Genesis Storm. It it really does some
good stuff for me.
Oh, do I need to cut Torstston?
Torstston is so good. That's such a good
card.
Yeah, cuz like this I think like 80% of
the deck is creatures and lands. So,
torsion is basically draw five cards.
So, that's that's pretty good.
Budget limit is
excluding basic lands cannot pass $25.
So, we are pretty tight here.
Um, let me see how much I look at how
much uh artifact enchant removal I'm
packing.
Um,
so we got that that doesn't count.
Two one-times.
Okay. So, less than I would like, I
think,
for for purposes of cutting druid of
purification.
Um,
so good. I can't cut it.
Charming Prince is fine, but like I I
want to mostly avoid the
one time single target flickers. I just
don't think they're what this deck is
really looking for.
If I optimize my printing, I'm at 26.
that. Okay. I mean, that's that's
getting closer for sure.
Uh, this is
maybe for a video. We'll see.
It's for for for a little project. We'll
see where it goes.
Let me see.
I don't know that I'm sold on Hornet
Queen. I threw this in as kind of like a
defensive card early. Um I just don't
know if this deck needs defense a whole
lot. I think I would rather just play
like a board wipe or something.
Flickering Hornet Queen feels
like it's
the
Yeah, we're going to we're going to move
that to maybe board for now. I mean,
it's not it's it's not cutting budget
for sure, but I just don't think I want
it.
Yeah, Zach deck. Zackfair is fine. I
don't know if this that's what this deck
is looking for. What it cuz it's like
one
I mean in principle it's not horrible
with uh Katilda just because it can pay
for its own um protection cost.
Yeah, I I I see it. I see the vision.
Um, I don't know for sure that I want
it, but
I I definitely see the appeal there.
If you have cards that someone put cards
on anyone's creatures, it can be a draw.
Oh, yeah. With a a generous patron card
is it's a solid card. I don't know if
that's what this deck is looking for,
but it is a pretty solid card.
Angel Angel condemnation is decent. I
would definitely consider it. Um I think
I have it in my maybe board.
Yeah, like it's it's a two mana value
turn.
Yeah, it's it's fine enough. Currently,
I'm running um
I guess I was just saying that I'm not
sure about Gilrain. Gilrain's pretty
decent. I think that's like a slightly
better version of Angel Condonation.
Basically, this I guess can
um
this can at least be a sort of removal
spell, but I don't know if that's really
what I need necessarily
decking challenge.
Nice. That's that's fun. Zy Zyuses. I
think Zyus Zyus is good as a commander.
And then um the the white the green
white like Doctor Who commander that
that's another really good one for like
a pump spell stack. That seems like a
lot of fun and I I would consider
building that out to have a a Zyus
variant.
Um, I
don't know that I need the tree tree
shaker chimera. I think I can do better
with with my draw.
Going to toss that.
Yeah, I think I got semester's end in
here. Yeah. Yeah, it's a pretty sweet
card.
Honestly, I'm almost inclined to just
cut
like my higher cost flicker like eternal
wanderer. Um, also that is something I
could do. I could cut conjurers closet
for
um
for woodland. Is that worth it?
Maybe I could see it. What all can Okay,
what all can Fierce Empath get? Cuz I
think that's going to determine a lot of
things here. library with a creature
code with mana value six or greater.
I know tree tree shaker tree shaker is
kind of a fun card. I
it might make it back in. I'm I'm not
I'm not discounting it forever, but I
don't know.
Um that's right. Mana value six or
greater creatures.
Uh
Torsten's good draw engine. I can grab
greenward moras. Although that's kind of
the same as the things it can grab.
It can grab a whole lot of removals.
Okay. So that if I were to if I were to
add the wooden bellware package in place
of conjurer's closet that could get me a
whole lot of removal.
Uh I guess technically it could get me a
flicker as well in the form of Pegasus
guardian. That's kind of neat.
There any other flickers it could get
me? No. The answer is no. Um,
seems okay. Uh,
let's see.
There any other like green
green creatures I could add?
I guess mana value less than three four
creature.
Yeah, John Benjamin was the one I was
thinking of.
Three three elk might say cut the
closet.
Uh clo closet closet is very nice but it
is
it is a bit for sure.
Yeah. Conjur's closet. I mean so in
principle I think my my density of ETB
is pretty high.
Like if I if I look up what are my ETBs?
It's like
yeah all those are ETBs.
Ratagas a little bit less but still kind
of I guess Garrick's back leader isn't
an E2B. Um so like six
I wouldn't really consider that need to
be six eight
all those are ATBs 17
kind of 18
yes like a quarter of the deck is
meaningfully useful ETBs for conjurers
closet which
hm
I don't know. I think we might try
cutting it. That that I think it seems
like a lot of fun to have a woodland
bellow package in here. So, I might go
ahead and cut this. Move it to the the
maybe board for now. Could see swapping
back, but we we'll try cutting. Let's
we'll see what we can do with wooden
bellware.
So, Bellware goes in.
We're going to call that
draw. Sure. I think all all the options
so far are value engines for being
grabbed.
One of Fortune. I I might add So what I
might do, I might add Fortune and
Kerodora so I have kind of a more
fleshed out flicker package.
Um,
yes, Ker Kadora is pretty sweet as a as
a thing to to Flicker.
Yes. So, let's go ahead and add that.
It's also a human. So, if I play it on
turn three, I can ramp into something on
turn four, unless I'm disrupted. But,
you know, that's not the end of the
world.
And then, yeah, let's throw in fortune.
I like fortune.
Fortune. I am a little worried that it
won't get in for attacks. Let me see
what what it's like a two4. Fortune
loyal steed.
ETB scry 2 attacks while saddled at end
of combat. It is a 24. So, as long as
somebody doesn't have like super thick
blockers, it might work.
I don't know.
I know. Yeah, I'm about to go three drop
hunting.
What do we got? That's too many cards.
Uh,
that's a more manageable number of
cards.
Are we talking like uh the green X arc
that's like destroy a non-creature
permanent
card definitely do I could I could look
for some of the budget tutor options. Um
it's like brutalizer exark.
Yeah, brutalizer XR creature on top of
it and shuffle.
Um,
how much is that? That's that honestly
not bad
expensive.
Yeah, Cilla
it it is a whole 50 cents. Although I
think that that doesn't matter too much
for uh budget decks. I your commander
can afford to be pretty expensive if
it's doing good good work. Okay, so if
we're looking for
we're looking for targets for woodland
bellor. So it's got to be non-leendary.
I guess I need to minus t legendary
non-leendary green three or less onto
the battlefield. Okay,
I could definitely throw in just like a
uh is there like a better I could do
some version of a Rex Age type thing.
Caligators is fine.
Um
all of Blossom Well, Blossoms probably
isn't good enough.
Um,
let's see.
Botanical Brawler,
Renegade Valor, and Sporal. Yeah, Knight
of Knight of Autumn was one I was
thinking of as a a kind of riff on
I would generally So, Povert Master asks
for protection in white, how do you
weigh protection from color versus
indestructible hex proof? I think it
depends on how much you're looking for
evasion because that is that is the
benefit of protection is you get around
blockers. Uh, in most situations for
protection purposes, I'm taking the hex
proof indestructible, but uh, protection
does get around blockers for sure.
You know, still gets board wiped by
probably more things than an
indestructible creature would, but um,
the the getting around blockers can be
pretty good.
And they're also just ones that are like
I think like the the one that has um
what is it? Rebound. That one's pretty
decent because you get protection
immediately and then your next turn you
get a rebound. You can, you know, get
protection from whatever you want to
swing in on and then just do some
massive swing.
Okay. Will malware targets
print lifter
ocean dissident
rift sweeper.
Oh, I did bad man value less than three.
That would be my issue. Okay. Um, Tyler
Proitioner is great. I think it's
probably it's like a buck 91. It's still
It's such a good card. We'll we'll we'll
we'll consider it. Um
uh
uh this list doesn't really have
enchantments. Not in any meaningful
numbers.
I don't think it even has any at all.
Yeah, M volley beast tracker doesn't
sure yeah I I can explain my my scryfall
things a bit. So uh this is low cost
creatures mana value less than four type
creature color green if it's color
equals because that's going to be
generally the stuff that's more useful
for like a a bigger flicker game plan
with woodbellower. Uh,
minus T legendary excludes legendary
cards. Minus mana X includes cards with
an X in their mana cost.
Scoochworm.
What else? I wonder if it's worth it for
her to run a wood elves. Probably not.
Like I could run wood elves over like my
existing rampish. So, like instead of
like core cartgrapher, I could run wood
elves. Um, it's not too bad. I might
consider that.
I don't know how to go how deep to go on
this package. I feel like once I'm at
like four or five cards, I think I'm
good, but I do want to get up to that
number. Um, Topiary Stomper is also
pretty good. How much? Yeah, 70 cents.
Now,
I don't need to pay an extra 50 cents to
get a little bit of power toughness. Um,
spring ding du is pretty decent. I think
what else is better?
I usually just sort by EDH ranking on
Skyfall, but that's just because that's
the way my brain processes it it better.
I I just find it easier to go to kind of
be in the mindset of, oh, I need to be
on the lookout for, you know, I'm
looking at good cards here. Oh, I'm
looking at slightly less good cards
here. Um, I don't know. It just kind of
puts me in the right frame of mind to
analyze cards.
Uh, Rejuvenator.
Oh, that does.
Oh, no. Wood Bellow makes her blade
elite so much better. Oh, no.
Oh no.
That's too tempting. I I don't I don't
think I can actually afford it. Um but
it's a fun card and it's obviously this
card goes nuts if I can play it and
something like a reverent hoplight or an
increasing devotion or you know drop a
bunch of lands with a maha in play.
Just a small thing.
Scattered groves included.
Uh, scattered gro. Yeah, scattered
groves. I think uh I figure there's got
to be some things that care about
forests. At least I have a couple lands
to do. So, like fortified village does.
Uh,
that doesn't count count basic type to
non-basic. So, that does not work. Um,
I'll definitely audit my mana base a bit
more later. Make sure I'm not running
too many tap lands because I am fairly
tap land dense right now. I'll have to
play test a little bit. Do some math.
Blood root apothecary. Um, we'll throw
knight of autumn.
Claim jumper is decent, but I don't
think I I really need catchup ramp here.
I think I'm going to be getting ahead
ramp.
Tranquil frill back.
Is that even good? I feel like that's
just worse than Night of Autumn. Oh,
it's also $2. Yeah,
it's not worse than Night of Autumn, but
because the grave exile is meaningful.
So, T my my theory with Timeless
Provisioner is that I want as many
eternal witness effects as possible,
which is to say I want three because
there are three of those that exist.
specifically three. I think Timeless
Witness is
Yeah, return target card.
How can I?
I I was not aware of that. Um, dragon
cards from Skyfall Architect.
But yeah, the idea is run a bunch of
those, you know, witness types run and
then, you know, currently I'm running, I
think, one, two, three,
four, four, four copies of exiling
number of creatures you control, return
them at the next end step, which in
theory, you can just kind of recycle
that and, you know, get a ton of value.
Um, lock down the board with a bunch of
removal engines. Uh going for some some
gross control shenanigans here.
Yeah, carving carried here would be a
blocker.
Good morning, Captain Scone.
Skullwinder actually is an ewood effect.
So I guess I can consider that. Um
definitely probably the the least I
would want one of these. Although that
one is I mean it's it's grabbable with
woodland bellor, but so is actual ewit.
So like I don't know. We'll consider it
for sure.
District guide.
Yeah, these aren't really getting
better. I wonder if there's like a is
there like an actual draw engine for
three minute or less in green. I kind of
wonder.
I guess there's like a augur of autumn.
I don't Is that How much money is that?
Is that might be might be under a buck
because that would be actually a really
decent grab off of
Yes. 89 cents from the dusk worm
printing. I would consider that
actually. That's pretty good.
If you have enough gray paint, I
honestly have very little gray paint
right now.
Uh, I should probably try and get a
little bit more in because I think I'm
just running the cave pit of offerings.
That's my only grave hate at the moment,
I believe. Unless I'm forgetting
something.
See, do I have any
I don't think I have any grave in my
sideboard either. Oh, no. I have
titanius command. Yeah, that's that
might be a good ad for both. It
stabilizes life total and then it either
ramps or it gets spared. I think that's
flexible enough.
Yeah, in fact, let's let's just get that
in there. It's a good card.
Uh we'll call it
Is it removal? I don't I don't know.
It's a The graveyard XL is going to be
good, I think. Um,
th Charm is decent. Although, yeah, th
Charm is good. Grave hate. That's That's
true. That's true. I might just look
through a bit uh and see if I can find.
Yeah, we'll throw the raven charm in our
possibilities list.
I definitely had the the thought for a
split second. Oh, I wish there was a a
board wipe that had graveyard exile on
it. And there there is, but
that is not a card that will young in
the deck. Uh
both because I hate it. If if it was
budget, I think for this specific deck,
I would run it. But I do not like
farewell in general.
Yeah. Yeah, absam beastmaster. I I
respect the beastmaster. I don't want to
hate on the beastmaster.
The beastmaster is not very good. It's
not It's not I respect it. I I
appreciate it.
Uh that's right.
What do we got? It's going to be
probably lands first. Yeah, forewell.
Scavenger grounds.
Return to nature would be like another
Thraven Charm style on that might be
better than what's the third mode on
Thraven Charm? I don't actually
remember.
The third mode is
Oh, yeah. Yeah, that destroys an
enchantment ex. Yeah. So, that's
probably a bit better than return to
nature. Actually, that's Wait, no,
that's that exiles the whole graveyard.
Any Yeah. No, that's a lot better than
return to nature. What am I talking
about? Okay, what else? Insurance
$7.
Um,
great hate. Great pay. Great.
I love interrupter. I don't think this
is the deck for hand. It's $2. Uh oh.
Where we going
is fortune a bit pricey? Oh no.
Okay. So it's it's
not that fortunate. Um, we'll throw that
in the flicker.
Legololis Green Leaf.
Legololis Green Leaf is fine. Um,
there's also like the one
classic budget draw engine. There's like
a I don't remember what it's called.
It's a green four drop cost two less for
your opponents have a green permanent
two three with death touch draws on
connection to a player. It's a solid
card.
I think soul of new forex is in my
sideboard already. It's not it's not
graveyard tape but
stone speaker crystal. I don't really
like
deepwood denison deep. That's no that's
that's the one that like cares about
plus one plus one counters. I think
that's that's not really what this deck
does not have enough of that.
Nautiloid ship is money I believe.
That's also money I believe.
Uh
for graveyard titania
have any attention is $3. Yeah. Okame
adversary is is what I was thinking of.
That that's a solid card. Like it's it's
certainly not bad.
Isn't graveyard isn't that 31 flash? Oh
yeah, Kitzel's. Uh,
no, you're totally right. I think
somebody mentioned it earlier. That one
is also ETB, so that one's likely.
Um,
yeah, Cuts Flanker,
I would definitely consider that one.
Um,
the fact that it has it's a graveyard
exile and it has other modes definitely
makes it pretty solid. We'll start with
Titanous Command. We got that there at
least. I think that's a really sweet
about exile with the modality and the
life gain there. Like being able to
stabilize like that is good. I probably
don't need pelorm if I've added a little
bit of life gain. Um I I need some life
gain but not a super massive amount.
Packorm is kind of a janky card.
I respect it. I love I love the worm.
The worm is great but
a little bit janky. Primal command.
Let's see.
What is that? That I remember one of the
mode is putting a creature on top of
your library or something.
Okay, that's actually No, that's that's
Yeah, I'll take it. No, that looks
lovely actually. Um,
fully axe the worm. I don't think
there's any chance it comes back in.
Yeah, primal command I like a lot
actually.
Oh, did it jump to the sideboard?
Yeah. No, we want that main board.
That's a good card.
Uh, I'm going to call that interaction,
but the fact that it tutors as well is
really sweet. I love that. Um, it can
grab like a bunch of centerpiece
creatures that it can grab that are
really great.
Um,
yeah, we'll call that removal.
No, not that.
Sentinel of lost lore
is seven cents. A three drop and exiles
a player's whole ass graveyard.
I'll have to look at that
removal.
Call that kind of draw. So, it's a two
drink for a good card is drawing cards.
Um,
I don't think the type really matters.
Sentinel of Lost Lore.
Is that Wait, is that the three mana 3
four guy? No, no, no, no. I mean, it is
a three four, but what what else?
Yeah. a two. You know, these texts
basically don't exist. So, it's
battlefield basically exalt players
graveyard. Yeah, I think that's kind of
similar to cuts flanker. It is grabable
with um
with woodland bellor, which I think
certainly is kind of interesting to me,
but I don't know. It's uh
I don't think it's it's it's just worse
than good sner by a fair amount. So, I
don't know that I feel the need.
So, I'm going to pop this in my flicker
category.
Does Titaneous Command fetch any lands?
It does fetch any lands. That's so
funny. You're You're right, Goldwin.
That's funny.
Mist breath elder.
So, it's a funny little frog guy. I
don't know that that is the flicker
solution I am dreaming of.
Palace Jailer is decent.
This is kind of a control deck, so I'm a
little nervous to put it in control.
It's amazing in aggro. It's amazing in
any fast deck. Um I'm pretty sure it
just
I think the Yeah, like it just gets
whacked.
Uh
so yeah, I don't I don't necessarily
uh the the the land tutor is Titania's
command. Six mana uh to do a bunch of
stuff including search for any two
lands. put them off the battlefield
tapped and then shuffle. Which honestly
grabbing like a wind brrist tights wind
brrist kites and a mossware bridge is
like really sick value actually. That's
super good. More than value. It's it's
because these these are you kind of like
a ramp thing. Verdant confluence.
I'm here for modal. What do we got?
Oh, this one.
Yeah, it's a it's a little bit uh less
tempting to me just because
I think I'm already kind of going hard
on the recursion just because I I need
it for my flicker package. Um so like
EWIT and Timeless Witness and such like
um
Sele Yeah, kind of Celelesnia human
flicker battle cruiser thing. Uh,
Outcast Trailblazer.
Zul Z was just a big dumb guy.
So, with my flicker effects, I just
added woodland bellow. I I cut Conjur's
Closet for it exactly, but I'm doing
kind of Woodland Bellow paired with
Semester's End type effects. Um,
actually, Ghost Way is a lot more
readable. Uh, just cards that exile your
creatures and then return them at end of
turn. I think those go great with like
Eternal Witness. They go great with uh
you know any any of these like recursion
creatures that grab any target. Eternal
Witness, Timeless Witness, Green Warden
of Murasa.
Um
yeah, Thal's Lancers grabs all sorts of
great stuff here.
My mic is cutting out sometimes. Why is
that?
Let me know if it gets bad and I'll I'll
investigate a little bit. Angel of
Glory's Rise is
seems okay.
See, what I know is going to happen if I
run Angel of Glory's Rise is I'm going
to let my commander hit the graveyard
and then I'm going to try and return it
and then I'm going to get my Angel of
Glory's Rise counterpelled and then I'm
going to be sad
because that's just what's going to
happen.
Um, oh, Sun Titan. Yeah, Sun Titan.
How in God's name did I miss the Sun
Titan?
Uh, yeah, actually, that's super good.
Sun Titan.
I think I just want that main board.
I mean, I guess so.
It does have a more limited range of
grabs in this deck than in some.
I might sideboard that for now actually
because I I think I have a kind of
limited. It's basically just lands and
I'm running like six three or less cost
cards currently
versus I did look at Salvation Swan and
the answer is mostly no. There are like
one or two but not a whole lot.
Hunter and village bell ringer. Uh
bellow does not grab white creatures. It
only grabs green creatures. Um
have to have some green in them.
Otherwise, yes, there are some definite,
you know, white things you can
do. But that's definitely
not workable unfortunately due to the
wording.
Yeah, but Bellawar still has a bunch of
good targets. It's an awesome effect in
any sort of flicker deck, so we can
still make it work. I'm glad to cut some
of the worst flicker here. Um,
is Pegasus Guardian not good enough? I
don't know.
Uh, another round is really good. Gale
Powder Mage is so good. Yeah, because
this one I can like land it on a turn
and then like the following turn I can
play something to to exile.
I think I'm going to run off and get
some water and use the bathroom. So, you
all better behave.
Oh, yeah. Fierce Empath needs to go in.
All right. It looks like you all you'll
behave yourself nicely. The ri the riot
failed. I hate to tell you,
but yeah, let's get
Let's definitely get Fierce Empath in
there for the tutor chaining
shenanigans.
This deck isn't running as many lowcost
humans as a lot of Catilda decks. So
is running it's running like a handful
of four drop humans which are nice and
then it's also running a handful of like
mass human generators which are like
um cigarda reverent hoplight
maha or maga. I like maha that sounds
spicier. And then uh increasing devotion
is like the other one that really like
gives you a big boost of humans.
Um sapphire is decent.
I'm trying to think. So, if I need I
need the the ETB creature to get in the
graveyard for that to happen.
So, I guess that'd have to be like a
board wipe, which I I am running some of
and I might add one or two more of. So,
I could see it.
Yeah. Maha blast.
That's Yeah, that's just how that's pron
any any word that has aja in it. It's
got it's got to be aha.
Oh, no. That's true. Yeah, I I'm
confusing people with the like black
removal engine. That's what Mahas is,
right?
Yeah.
It's this gross guy.
Yeah, I'm sure I'm sure this stream is
at a great time for uh anybody in in
Europe.
I I started at like 8:30 a.m. my time
just because I was up and wanted to
build a deck and uh thought it'd be fun
to have that streamed.
Okay, how many cards we at? Okay, we're
105.
Am I done looking at these? Let me let
me go through a handful more and then
we'll call it good.
Moana Vully, Beast Tracker.
I don't think I actually have many good
options for one voy like in I always
look at this card and I'm like that
looks great. Uh but it doesn't put it
into hand and then it also Yeah, they're
just not there's just so many cards that
just don't have those keywords.
Um, Luren is good, although I think it's
still a couple couple bucks. And
uh, people saw me struggling with Druid
of Purification earlier and that was 90
cents. So,
yeah, that's kind of where I cap out on
what I'm willing to spend on removal
here.
The Cascade I could so I could see
cutting um, I could potentially see
cutting Cascade. I in principle I like
it as like a way to dig deeper into the
library, but it definitely gets worse
the more kind of two three drop stuff I
put in. Granted, it's still not a lot
currently. Like it's like, you know,
that much uh you know, two
non-commander, two drops, six
non-commander or six three drops.
Uh failure has gotten a lot cheaper. Um,
it's like two bucks at this point, but
my first favorite color was black and I
think that is still my my favorite
color. I I tend to brew in black a lot.
Just a big fan of all the the stuff
there. Big fan of paying life to draw
cards and other such things.
See, I might cut the eternal wanderer.
That might just be worse than the other
flicker options.
It's like no more than one creature can
attack the eternal wanderer each combat.
But there are going to be three combats
before my turn. So,
see, for each player, choose a creature
that player controls each player.
No, that's just a good board effect.
Yeah, this this seems good enough.
It's a It's a It's a pretty sweet card.
Woodfall Primus. I ran in Rada for a
while and I just found that the eight
mana felt a little clunky. Like it's you
don't want to pay eight mana to remove
one thing. Like you compare that to
something like Protector of the Wastes
that exiles two things for six mana and
it's
Yeah, it's it's
hard to justify. Same with like Angel of
the Ruins, like the white options. Even
Terraadon, I think I'm probably going to
cut at some point here just because I
don't really love
um yeah, I can see cutting the Cascade.
I I I'm not particularly
uh I think I probably like Natural
Wreck. I found a lot of success with
that and I like having that as an
instant speed play. Um, but I think
something like an enlisted worm or an
annoyed altaur is definitely maybe a
little more mid, not not necessarily all
that good. So, I could definitely see
cutting this.
This deck is definitely doing something
kind of fundamentally different than
what the the rat deck is doing.
Like, it's still it would still be nice
to hit like my ramp off of it.
H
I don't know. I I feel like I need to
play test this deck a bit to to get an
idea of what's going on with it.
We're at 2822. That's not too bad.
Need to cut out a little bit of value.
Eternal Wonder is your Bethl theme
board. Yeah, Eternal Wonder is great.
some card draw or something.
Andre's 4Runners is solid. Um,
yeah, I don't really have
most of my flicker doesn't isn't most of
my flicker is not the sort of flicker
that works with endra for runners. I
think almost all of my flicker is exile
returned at end of turn
and that's not all that great with uh
Andreas
uh in in in theory. Well, so the way I
think about it is natural reclamation
gets better the more I have to play at
instant speed because I have options. If
I can choose between natural wrecking at
instant speed or semester's ender end
ending at instant speed, that's that's
that's a good choice to be able to make.
Um, so I think broadly I I like natural
wreck in this deck. I think the the the
the dino and the worm I could go either
way on. Sweet gum recluse I've just had
a lot of success with. That one's also
flash. So that one is definitely staying
as well. But these these top two I think
are are very much cutable.
um two different
I don't think I like duplicant or
terrassidon a whole lot honestly. Um
let me let me look at what what what I
had. I threw a bunch of stuff in here.
Um so there was like yeah duplican's
cheap. Highly cliff fellar is really
good creature removal but that's two
bucks. Um,
Koga is great, but that's creep crept up
to a buck 50. This is probably a no-go.
Honestly, I think I'd probably do meteor
Golem before duplicant, but I I don't
like either all that much. It's just it
just seems kind of clunky.
Resolute.
I could see adding Resolute back in.
That's a really good card. That's a
really good card.
O
um I don't think I'm instant speed
enough to for wilderness rack. Uh yes, I
do have uh pardon gust.
Um
links in chat. Uh as long as it doesn't
get like clogged up with everybody
trading deck lists, then that's fine.
also don't like
send some sketchy virus I I
also don't know if I need to enable
links in chat somewhere. I probably just
won't bother.
Um, Resolute Archangel seems really good
for like a slower deck, so I might try
and crowbar that back in. That seem that
seems quite good.
Toss that in stabilization.
Uh, is there more payoff? There there's
there's some payoff. So, um,
I haven't actually looked recently, but
there's a decent I tried to put in a
decent number of like four drop humans.
Um,
I didn't realize both witnesses were
humans. That's pretty good. Uh, so
there's like this one might be cutable.
Honestly, this this is I'm questioning
that a little, but there's like Yeah,
there's a bunch of horost humans which
kind of let you go a little bit flexible
on your ramp. And then there are a
couple really big human generators. Um,
specifically,
uh, Cigarda, Reverend Hoplight,
Maha, and increasing devotion all can
turn out a lot of humans. Um, I'm
inclined to get rid of the these cascade
things.
Um,
throw that into the
assorted bucket.
So, this deck is mostly higher cost
stuff, so I'm probably not looking for
bounce. I think that's just going to
really like
be kind of a a
self-defeating type of card.
The curve out with Rip is pretty sweet.
Um,
yeah, any number of different creatures
or vehicle cards
running like 40 creatures. On average,
you get one to two. I'll say one. On
average, you get one creature off of
RIP.
That's
fine. That's okay.
It's fine. Um
I don't know. I I could go either way on
RIP. I It's only 14 cents, so I'm not
feeling particularly glad to cut it
right now, but um could be cut.
Okay, what else do we got going right
now? I
I almost kind of want to cut the things
that
find only creatures.
Wy Duke is another one that I
considered. I
I don't know.
It's an okay draw engine. It's not
terrible.
But it like it needs needs the commander
in order to draw cards.
Yeah, I'm running Mangara currently.
Um, it's definitely one of those cards
that like it's just expensive enough
that I consider cutting it, but then I
go back and read the text and I'm like,
"Yeah, it's going to be drawing a lot of
cards. I need that." Um, honestly, I
might be more inclined to cut Ratagast
just because it cannot find my flicker
and that kind of hurts. Um, I think I
really want to be able to find like a
Lazel acrobatics or something. I think
that that like immediately turbocharges
my game plan. I'm probably shooting for
a low bracket three here. Um, it's a
it's kind of hard to shoot higher than
that with a $25 deck. Uh, unless you
like really hone in on like a combo
commander or something.
Um, yeah, I'm going to cut Ratagast. I
don't feel like that's going to be doing
enough.
I'm sorry. Ratagast is not terrible.
Ratagast is a lovely card. I simply
don't know if I want it in this
instance.
Um, yeah, Garrick's Uprising. Actually,
I for a while I thought that was
expensive, but I think that one's
actually gotten a lot cheaper, so I
threw it in my maybe board. Um, yeah,
that's probably a better draw engine.
Let me double check my my powers.
Power greater than three.
Um 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
actually less than I would expect I
think. Yeah, that's like
excluding the vehicle. That's like 17 18
total.
I don't know. I'm I don't know that I'm
sold.
I do I do need I think more draw is
going to be good though. So I should
keep an eye out for that for sure.
Roll cruel claw.
Yeah, for sure. Tedus.
What does Tedus do?
Right.
H.
Yeah. So, it's like a it's like a it's
like a grazax basically in green white.
Also a human. I could see. Yeah, I could
see it.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
We'll throw them maybe bored and then I
But yeah, that seems pretty decent.
Perhilion is another finisher.
I don't think
I don't think I need a parhelion here.
I'm honestly debating if I need even
need the Zulpa, but it's also just such
a good blocker that I think that kind of
makes it worthwhile for me. Um,
I definitely threw together a $25 winota
deck a little while back and it was uh
disgusting. Like if the commander gets
removed on turn
for you're in trouble, but like they
need instant speed removal for that and
then if you get a swing in with like
three non-creature dudes, it just it
just starts going out of control really
really fast. It's hilarious.
Zatopa is Yeah, Zotopa is just a big
guy. Uh I I've seen it in action. It's
pretty good. It just it just kind of
whacks people really hard and blocks
well. But yeah, I I could go either way
on it. Um I'm also thinking of pumping
up the board wipe count in this deck if
I can find a bunch of cheap white board
wipes. Um and actually I already know I
want cleansing no. Oh, is there cheaper
printing? Cleansing Nova
Midnight Hunt 44 cents. That's looking
better
removal
her
trailblazer. Yeah, outcast Trailblazer
is a pretty decent card.
How much is that these days?
Yeah, for 92 cents. It's a little hard
to justify.
Evra is ever is the life swap one, isn't
it? That
That's a different sort of card. Very
funny card, but
Project Oh, yeah. Project Guardian is
going to be out of budget. That's like a
$10 card still.
Catastrophe. Catastrophe sounds like
something that is destroying lands, but
I don't actually know if it is.
Catastrophe.
Probably think of cataclysm.
Nope, that is destroying lands.
Yeah, I'm not going to be picking the
former option if this is a big mana
deck. I still need to play test this
deck a bit and figure out how often it
curves out the way I want it to.
Yeah,
is also not quite what I'm looking for.
Split up. Split up is really good. Yeah.
Um
yeah, I I do need board wipes to be
pretty cheap because I I'm spending
pretty big in some other areas,
specifically woodland, bellware, draw,
and flicker. That's going to be eating
up most of my budget. So, I think I need
everything else to be like really cheap.
Um in fact, I should probably real quick
audit my ramp and make sure there's
nothing too pricey here.
Primeval Herald. Oh, there's not a
cheaper printing of that, I don't think.
Like, is the original printing was worth
like three bucks at some point? I'm
guessing it probably still buck 50 or
something. Oh, it is a little cheaper.
Okay.
Is it? I actually remember.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Go jump start 2022.
I'm going to be I I need to cut back
down to
uh I need to cut four cards and then
I'll try some test hands because I I do
want to give give a good round of
testing to this. Um I I do need to know
that, you know, the fundamentals of the
deck work basically.
Um,
dragon storm secutus route. There
cheaper printing of secutous route.
Divine reckoning. Is that the one that
exiles non-token creatures?
Doesn't really do it for me. Battle of
the Bwater keeps ewits. Interesting.
Oh, that right. Yeah, some throwback
Innistrad
nonsense. Yeah, I
I think this very frequently is going to
be missing what you wanted to kill with
your board wipe. So, that is not
something that's tempting me unless I
have like exactly one creature I care
about.
Um, I think I I did I cut um
I cut the two sorcery speed cascaders. I
like sweet I personally like sweet gum
recluse and natural reclamation good
enough to keep them in. I I think
they're just pretty decent in a in a
somewhat slower, more controlling deck.
Um, expel the interlopers is is really
good.
Um,
yeah. I don't know this going to be all
that great in this deck, but like it's
it's a you know, for it's looking pretty
cheap, so I might just toss it in. Um,
although I guess yeah, the the
alternatives would be like route for
like an instant speedboard wipe. Um,
that means if I'm at like 11 mana, I can
do like a uh Lazelle's Acrobatics, then
board wipe on somebody else's turn,
which is kind of fun.
Yeah. 27.81. Yeah. So, I'll I'll see if
I can cut Eternal Wonders is good. Let's
go price. We'll see if we can cut some
some pricier stuff.
Yeah,
Ewit. Let me see if there's a cheaper
printing of EWIT. I
Yeah, I can do price optimizing later.
This is this is not something to worry
about. Okay. Torsten, founder of
Banelia. So, the one thing I don't like
about Torston is that he does not find
um
like instance of sorceries.
That's
not my favorite thing, but the card is
really good otherwise. So, I find it a
little hard to cut.
Golden Argusy.
I like this card. Okay.
No, I like this card more than okay.
This is a pretty good card because it it
it is when it attacks. So, you don't
even need to hit combat damage.
Beans is definitely something I'm
considering cutting just because like
there's a lot of payout for it. Like if
I look at where I'm at right now with
mana values, uh
it's like
30 basically 30 on the nose, which it's
a fair amount.
Uh, Mangara.
Yeah, Eternal Witness. Du of
purification.
Starfall invocation is actually pretty
good.
It is 67 cents.
Although
The golden argusy. Yes. Uh yes, this is
a a cat deck.
It is I lubricate snail.
Yeah. Uh, let me let me just find some
real quick cuts. I'll worry about budget
later. I just need to know if the the
fundamental idea of the deck pans out.
Okay, so I could probably cut a little
bit of flicker. Uh, did I have payoffs
for like Pegasus Guardian?
Uh, he actually kind of did. Fierce
Empath grabs Pegasus Guardian. So, I
think that's good enough justification.
Partigus is just good.
Uh, I don't know if I'm sold on my
current
package.
Like I got Mysterious Limousine.
I got Golden Argusy. I Is this card even
good? Okay. When it enters, it exiles a
thing till it leaves.
Enters or attacks.
That just seems really slow. I don't
know.
Uh, this deck was inspired by I want to
build a $25 deck for reasons. And uh, I
I figured I would try I would I would
try out a a Rata riff. I didn't want to
literally just build $25 Rata because
that feels boring. Um, but I I do want
to try out uh some version of a $25 Rata
style deck. Um,
yeah, Kerodor is good. I
uh, the issue with Kodor is that the
only things I want to grab are fortune
and golden argy. Let me, let me do a
quick search through.
First of all, let me see what must be
done. Somebody mentioned that.
Uh,
choose one. Yeah. Uh,
how much is Realm Cloak giant these
days? If it's cheap, I would go with it.
Yeah. No, that seems fair enough.
I will put my board and probably edit.
a future vid maybe. Yes, indeed.
Uh,
oh yeah, I was going to check out
vehicles real quick to see T vehicle
code identity less than or equal to
green white.
Um,
give me the EDR rankings. I'm guessing
there not going to be a whole lot that's
that appealing here.
Yeah, that's not
Weather Light is okay draw. It does also
if I if I go a little bit harder on
um board wipes, I think it becomes
decent.
How many how many legendaries do I have?
We're rocking like I'm just going to
throw the top in the baby board right
now. I don't
uh let's let's just get that out of here
for now because I I don't I want eight
mana cards to do a lot. Uh, okay. So,
with that, we've got 12 legendaries.
Yeah, I don't think I don't think
Weather Light's gonna be doing it. Okay,
that that is Kerdori is where Parhelion
does become more tempting.
Uh, so I
[Music]
I starting to respect that suggestion
more.
Um,
So, this is going to be I think a
slower, more controlling deck. So, I
think Resolute Archangel does become
pretty good. Um, whether it's worth a
buck 07 is definitely a question. I
think I also had something like uh
I I had some other version of it like
uh some giant or other
some ETBs I think. Yeah, Arbiter of
Noridge, which that that would be like
an alternative
uh angel basically. I could see it. Um
Archon of Valor's Reach, I could see
that being a little bit weaker in this
deck than in some. I think it makes a
really good topend card for a hate bears
deck. Um but I don't I don't think this
deck is trying to do quite the same
thing. I think it's more looking for
like a removal engine rather than uh
like stacks. So I'm inclined to cut this
for now.
Cut the green and add red instead.
Yeah, let's get that out of there. Uh,
okay. Going back down this list.
Uh, Sika's Chariot
is a card that I don't think actually
does a whole lot in this deck.
Regal. Yeah. Is that Wait, that one's
pretty decent, right?
Um I don't think it's turn three ramp
notably. Uh but it is ramp. Yeah. So it
does need a crew one. So if you tap out
uh tap out the commander turn three, you
cannot crew it. Um but if if I'm looking
for vehicles, I think that one still is
pretty solid. Let me just throw that.
Oh, no. You're right.
Yeah, that probably won't make it in.
Okay, never mind.
Maybe later.
Oh, I know. Yeah, I uh
I am looking forward to
I'm I'm definitely going to try and
build an aa deck because I've been
messing around with various token copy
decks recently. Uh, and that card is a
lot of fun with those.
Oh, I see. Yeah, somebody mentioned
Lumbering World Wagon.
Um,
I think I like that pretty well,
actually. Better than the regalia. So,
and that is actually a turn three ramp.
It's crew four, but I got some chunky
guys in this deck, so I think that
should be fine.
Um, yeah, that was one of the No, not
not that
colossal plow. What is that
vehicle based ramp?
If it's a white ramp, I'm kind of
worried it's catchup ramp, which is not
necessarily what this deck is looking
for
philosoph.
I don't I don't think I'm seeing
anything else here that's striking my
eye
colossal plow. I see. Ooh, crew six. Oh,
wow. That is a juicy crew number.
Wow. It does have three white. Um,
yeah, that's
interesting.
Seems a little bit challenging. What's
the other one? Uh, guardian sun.
Guardian summary is an actual
consideration here, I think.
There there are a nonline permit.
No, but it is searching my library, so
that works fine.
I
kind of like that.
Yeah, I need I need to go through other
mountains now.
Um,
I like Bor Ox in principle, but I don't
think this is a Boric Ox deck.
I don't think District Mascot does much.
Um,
Humble Wag also doesn't do much.
Yeah. Yeah. I think Guardian Summer is
like the one card that's actually
interesting here.
Yep. Okay. Yes. I mean there there
definitely I think there are probably
enough options to to make a car practice
work out. Okay, let's let's cut some
stuff. Uh
probably more expensive stuff.
Do I need ghostway? Ghost way is really
good.
Let's axe the limousine.
I don't really use our tags. Um,
sometimes I'll remember they exist and
start using them, but I have frequently
found that they're
incomplete or not quite what I'm looking
for. So, I've just gotten kind of good
at using basic skyfall.
Uh, I don't know that I'm feeling
fortune, honestly.
Yeah, let's cut fortune and then let's
which I I I makes the car door package
look pretty garbage right now. I'll cut
bar instead. Actually, bear doesn't do
much.
Sarafic steed isn't terrible,
but like
it's just a beater.
Um, Blade of Prototype is a card I could
put in. Honestly, that's a card that's a
good candidate for my Rata deck actually
because it that is not in good removal
colors.
Okay,
let's see. Turn three acceleration
is
Yeah, I guess some amount of that.
Honestly, we might be low on turn three
acceleration. Although, there are a fair
amount of alternate turn four or like
two, three, four drop plays, so it could
work.
Okay, that's good enough. Yeah, we keep
that.
Temple plenty. What we got on top?
Lovely. Keep it there.
play Catilda.
We play a
rangers path.
Searching up the dual forests, I think.
play tapped. Do I have another dual
forest? Yeah, I think I have the Yeah,
it's that one, too. That one pro the the
cycle the bicycle end probably gets cut,
but we'll see.
Okay. Yeah. So, we're at this point.
Uh
could play the Maja to start to build up
a board of humans. Um I kind of want to
do that. Present a threat. hold of the
the wind briskites.
So we got that. We got wind kites gets
us a human.
Need to clear out my sideboard so I have
less here.
And then one, two, three, four. Wow,
that's a full whiff.
Is it play?
Yeah, play. Uh, yeah, I'll take the
vault to vault, I guess. I'm just gonna
put that there.
Okay, let's say for the sake of argument
that Maha doesn't get removed.
Okay, so now that's Golden Argusy.
Suddenly that sets up like a sick Angel
of the Ruins Timeless Witness play.
Um,
yes. We play Golden Argusy.
We play
Vastwood Surge. Getting a couple more
lands. That's going to get us three more
humans total for this turn, which is
pretty good.
Play card. Play card.
Yeah, that's that's And then we have a
ton of mana next turn. We do some gross
stuff with that. That's that's not bad.
Um,
let's see.
Okay. So, that this is where Okay. You
know, we This actually works out pretty
well.
Maha Blast. Yeah. Uh this hand is
actually kind of sick, I think. Yes. We
Mosswer, you know, we turn one Mwar, we
grab, you know, something Sunblast
Angel. Uh Ghost Way is definitely what
we get here.
Ghost way, I think, just goes crazy in
this deck.
Yeah, we we do got that Argusy. Uh,
untap.
Play the commander.
Untap.
Uh, play the village. Play.
What are we doing first here? I think we
need to get build up mana initially.
Um, dual dragon storm.
Next turn
we have
h.
Yeah, I think we we just have to play
the beantock plus I think like a
could go beantock plus argusy. Yeah, I
think that's the move. And then suddenly
we can flicker next turn. Um
play a land for turn. Draw a card off of
beantock.
Next turn
we have Solemn plus Argusy to get a
little bit of more ramp. This is like a
little bit slower of a roll out, but I
think it turns out okay. Like we just
have a lot of grind here. Um if my
commander gets removed, this puts out
three things after I recast her at the
beantock and potentially get some draws.
I think this is pretty solid.
Yeah, Maha's Maha is quite good. Let's
try another
um
Yeah, that's that's that's a
it's okay.
I am I am building a new uh
brewing out trying out a uh $25 kind of
uh riff on my router deck uh for
purposes for a potential video. Um
I don't know whether this is going to
end up working out the way I like, but I
figure it's worth trying.
Director of Sad Robot. Oh, no. I I I am
a Sad Robot defender.
Everybody else in the world hates Sad
Robot, but I I will defend Sad Robot.
I can see mulling this. Yeah.
Yes. We do that. We get robot out. We
grab a
Yeah, this hand didn't I mean we we get
increasing devotion out which I is nice
because they basically have to remove
the humans because removing Katilda
doesn't really do anything.
Uh so I think that ends up feeling
pretty good. If they remove Katilda, we
get to do a sick Genesis Storm play.
Yeah, it's still a bit over budget right
now. It's not uh
it needs to be cut down a little, but
it's not the end of the world. Um yeah,
some good plays there.
Um
yeah, that's pretty solid. Uh we got the
ramp, we got the the lands.
Might even play Mangara turn three,
honestly. That that just starts grinding
card advantage really well.
draw a tapland turn two. Of course,
tilda.
Yeah. So,
we'll play Mangara. Let's see.
If I get a
If I get a 11 to 15, I get one card. If
I get a 16 to 20, I get two cards.
That's a nine. And I don't get cards.
All right. Play Tapland. Encroaching
Dragon Storm. Actually, I could play I
don't really have a six drop really.
The Emperor of Palamasia. I I'm not I'm
not familiar with that.
Play that. Get a couple things. Yeah,
this game is definitely a little bit
This is very much depends on Mangara to
to get us going here.
Yeah, it's fine enough.
Yeah, this game is not ideal. Surveyor
getting gave her pit of offerings or
even citadel is so good. Yeah, I don't I
don't have
Yeah, wayfair's bubble's good. I like
it.
Um, I think it depends a little bit.
Like if you're running a whole bunch of
colors, it's going to be less common or
I guess it depends on the number of tap
lands you have. If you have a lot of tap
lands, you're going to be paying
effectively three mana for the card,
which is awkward. But if you can play it
on turn one a fair amount or like weave
it into your mana curve somewhere uh for
the one mana and then have it it can
kind of feel like a ramping growth,
which is the ideal situation, obviously.
Yeah, we do not keep that on the first
go round.
Yeah. What is this emperor card?
The emperor
of Palamasia.
Palamsia.
What do we got?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cast another spell at least for us.
Transform it. What's the backside?
That's kind of sick actually.
That seems like a lot of fun because
that backside bombs people pretty hard.
I like the dragon storm enchantments
generally. I mean I think the red one's
kind of what what is the red dragon
storm? It's like a a like creative
technique type thing from top of the
library until you exile an online card.
You may cast it without paying cost. Um
this one's just
Like this isn't even not what the deck
wants. The card is just not very good is
my issue with it. Um
like if it was four mana I would like it
but it is five mana which is not the
right amount of mana. Encroaching
dragontor Storm is lovely. I am happy to
run that always.
Okay this was my opening hand. This is
not a keep the first time around. Maybe
not even the second time around. Well,
mulligan.
Uh,
that is also a mulligan down to six.
Um, it's got a hidden nursery. We can
try and grind a little bit of value.
It's not too bad.
Wait.
Oh, well.
Yes. So, we're drawing more and more
ramp, which honestly I found um in this
style of deck that's not the end of the
world. Uh because you can just kind of
chain a bunch of ramp.
Do I have a cave I want right now? I
don't think so.
Dragon Storm. We'll get some
play card. play card.
Maybe tap play a tapped hidden nursery.
Tap four for another fastwood surge and
then hope we draw something is roughly
how this goes.
Do I not have I not upgraded my rattle
list with the green dragon storm?
It it is in my paper deck. Uh I promise
you that
I have all these decks.
[Music]
It's explosive dragon storm. What is it?
Encroaching dragon storm. Yeah, I forgot
to add it. What? What did I end up
cutting for it? It was like uh
is it path
frontier? Something like that.
I think it was this one actually.
I should double check if there's
anything else I'm missing from this list
at some point.
[Music]
Uh, I'm working on a Catilda
kind of ratta variant. I was just doing
a little bit of play testing. I need to
see if I draw garbage or not.
Play card.
How we looking?
What's our draw?
That's pretty bad. Okay, so we're kind
of running out of cards. What happens if
I flip the nursery? Does that hit
something? Maybe
hits Path of the Animist.
It's one of those classic games where I
draw nothing but ramp.
Honestly, not the worst thing that could
happen. I would rather draw nothing but
ramp than miss land drops. Honest to
God, it works out better in the the long
term. Um,
I think this is a fine opening hand,
honestly.
Like, I need to draw payoff. I might see
if I need to add more uh more ETB um
cards cuz I obviously have the payoff.
I'm drawing the payoff just fine.
Oh, yeah. I saw the new explosive
vegetation. I think at this point I
really don't need anymore. Like I've
I've kind of gotten enough.
There's a lot of versions of explosive
edge. I'm already kind of playing the
good ones.
Play card.
Kind of flooding a little bit.
Maybe we'll keep up the white
interaction. Uh,
play tap land. That's fine.
Yeah, I I mean, I think it depends. So,
if you have if you have bursty card draw
that starts generating a lot of value
for you, uh flooding can allow you to
catch back up super hard later,
especially if you're flooding in both uh
ramp and lands. Uh lands plus ramp
drawing nothing but that for a while.
You know, the table's not going to be
looking at you too hard, and you're
going to,
you know, have a ton of mana for when
you eventually do find some stuff. Um
you just need to have the draw in there
to find it eventually.
Yeah, this is kind of going rough. I
need to try one more game, but it seems
like I might need more just
smoothing
uh draw type stuff.
This is a nice deck. This a nice hand.
Um
guess we'll go Windrisk.
One, two, three, four. Wow, it's a lot
of lands that exile.
move to bottom of library.
It also depends on your mana curve a lot
because if you have a high mana curve,
uh hitting a ton of lands and ramp can
feel a lot better because all you need
to do is draw like a handful of like
high cost cards and then suddenly it
feels like you're playing Magic again.
Um, okay. See, here we're drawing some
of our good stuff. invasion
of Zendicar on somebody. Grab a couple
lands.
This this this is very similar to my rat
deck. This is not not very very similar.
Like I think the end game plan is very
different. It's running a lot less
cascade, a lot more flicker. Um but it
it is kind of structurally
choosing the same path in terms of
resource gaining.
So I don't have a specific wing card in
mind. I might test a little bit. Oh,
it's a fat wasp in my room.
It's like a unique type of wasp. One of
those guys with the strange and spindly
appendages.
Uh, okay. What What am I doing here?
Yeah, that's right. playing my sweet gum
recluse
and then hope we hit something good.
Druid of purification. Sure.
Is using Katilda as the two mana dork.
Although there is a lot more utility
here for Katilda than the Rata deck has
for Rata. Like there there are a bunch
of kind of human generators. And what I
like about that is that even if Katilda
gets knocked out, if you just generate a
bunch of humans, like pay for four, even
play Katilda for six, if you just have a
bunch of humans, then you can just kind
of make back up that mana.
Stay over there.
Uh
what was I doing? Oh yeah, I got boot of
purification. Okay, that was that game.
So I I I've thought about kind of making
verdians. I don't think green black
actually has a dork in it. Um but the
other color combos definitely do. Uh
I I don't know. It's an option, but I'm
I'm I like the deck a lot, so I find it
fun brewing them, but uh I I really only
need one of them in my actual deck.
I know. Yeah. Hornet queen coming for
for revenge.
Yes. I think I just need more kind of
smoothingish draw. Um I do have some
number I I do have some number of
tutors. I'm just not finding them
currently.
Like I I think tutors wise I have I've
got Wow, we're not loading. Okay, there
we go. All
right, categories singular.
Tutors wise, I think I have a fair
amount. Like I've got fierce empath and
woodland bellow, which can both find
each other. Um I've got where was it? Uh
primal command, which that finds a
thing. I I think in principle I have
enough draw. Maybe I'm just not finding
it.
Oh yeah, this Belby. Belie's
fascinating.
Yeah, the the Kellen version seems kind
of fun. Um,
yeah, I I think this is looking decent.
I I've definitely built up the value
engines here a lot. Uh, like there are
just so many flicker nonsense
engines. I think we need probably a
couple more pieces of like more generic
draw. So, I might see if I can cram in
something like a a Garrick's Uprising, a
Lenor,
uh maybe a maybe a Tedas. I think there
there's some good options here, but
feeling pretty good about this in
general.
Things are
looking pretty good.
Oh yeah, Arixes you can do
you can do things with. Actually, I did
something similar with GoreClaw in the
sense that I I ran a ton of
ton of two meta ramp. Uh not a ton, like
15 pieces. Honestly, it was a
surprisingly low number, but it it
worked out. Uh and then just the rest of
the deck was a whole lot of like four,
five, six mana creatures just to like
start dumping out. Uh, and that was that
was fun, but it was so so fragile
compared to Rata. Um,
in inverting the the curve is
so much more impactful than you would
think. Like the fact that explosive edge
gets two lands h having your main having
your like core ramp card get two lands
rather than one is just such a huge
difference. Um,
you know, if it it doesn't even feel bad
to flood out on the the ramping two
cards just because you just start to
build up such a stupid high. Yeah, that
that died if we got board wiped. Yeah.
Uh, I think a fair amount of it was
creature based ramp, but I think even if
you managed to like fit in as many like
rocks or like rampant growth effects as
possible, I think you would still have
trouble just because uh just drawing
rocks feels bad. Drawing explosive
vegetation doesn't really feel bad, but
drawing rocks does not feel good.
Preexian portal. Is there a card called
Prexian portal?
There is a card. If your library has 10
or more cards in it, target opponent
looks at the top 10 cards of your
library and separates them to two face
down piles.
Search the other pile for a card.
That is a strange card. It's really
funny though.
That's a really really funny card. I
don't think it's what I'm looking for,
but it is a really funny card.
Yeah, semic. I think I'd probably do
just Kellen.
It I I would probably do Kellen.
Do Kellen. Run the companion.
You probably have to run a couple extra
lands like 40. I'd probably go 43 or 44,
maybe some utility lands in there just
because Kellen requires having an extra
land to put into play. So, you want to
be safe. Um, but the fact that you have
card draw in the command zone means that
I think you can really afford not card
draw in the command zone, card draw in
the companion zone means I think you can
afford to run a little bit more lands.
Yes. Currently, my only three color deck
is Sheroom.
Um, I should build some more three-color
decks. They're they're they they have
some appeal to them. But yes, that is
currently the case.
Um,
let's scoot over to
this imscar deck. I feel pretty good
about the the green white one. I think
that one's pretty solid.
This one is I don't think on my profile,
but I can definitely link it in the the
description.
Yeah, the VOD will be up
actually. Let me
current deck list.
There we go.
Yeah, this is one that I feel I think is
a in a lot more of a hammered out state.
Um, it's kind of a fast impure deck. Uh,
I spent so long figuring out how to fit
Luminar Seras into the budget because
it's so good. It's so good in IMSR. You
like drop it on three. Some games you
can get Imar on four and then sacrifice
it immediately get SE uh eight black.
It's crazy.
Um, yeah, this is kind of an an
aggressive riff on Imcar. You can
definitely do like a more grindy thing
with like a bunch of high cost
artifacts. Yeah, Spinoish saw definitely
is a pretty wild one. This deck I don't
think has the the mana production for
that. Maybe it does. I don't know.
But yeah, I MCQ is a lot of fun. Uh
I probably need to look at the removal
suite just to make sure I'm able to hit
permanent types. Um,
I have one,
two,
three
currently. Is it three ways to remove
artifacts?
One way to remove enchantments. I think
Chisori is so good.
Slowbad does something similar, but this
deck is not running that many high cost
artifacts. Um, it is it is a a much more
it's it is a fairly low curved ISCR
deck. First ability dominant I would
say. So we we are looking to draw a lot
of cards off of an early Imcare play and
leverage that into kind of a a good
beatd down game plan.
Experimental synthesize. I I looked at
that and I I have been destroyed by that
card in Popper, but I don't think it
actually does anything at all in this
deck. Um
yeah, if the toko is an artifact, maybe.
But I don't think so.
It's a great card though.
I'm glad. I honestly I think the budget
deck building is a lot of fun. Oh no,
the budget crept up. Uh, it definitely
gives you the chance to to to flex some
some muscles that you wouldn't normally
get to flex. Uh,
like just like needing to evaluate every
single card like, "Oh god, 96 cents. Can
I afford 96 cents? Dear god, that's so
expensive."
Uh, did I still running scraper? I think
I cut scrapler from this deck. Yeah.
No, I uh I I can't decide if I want it
or not. Like it's it's a fine card. Um
it goes really good if I start doing
some sort of like kind of aristocratsy
sacrifice thing, but I don't know if
that's actually what I'm doing. Uh
one card, Fireexian Portal.
We have Fireexian Portals greatest
soldier here advocating. Um one thing
I'm kind of wondering is whether
Nimshrier is good enough. Uh because I
flying makes it I think better than the
rest of the nim. Uh like if I can get
like six or eight artifacts that's
hitting pretty hard. Uh but
[Music]
I don't know. It's It's still kind of a
janky nonsense. I I also don't know how
much ping there is. I I don't know how
much ping to expect to be facing. So, I
could see this going kind of uh badly if
there's Bing. Sahil's Lattice.
I remember it's a two- mana artifact
that does something.
Yeah, discard a card, draw two cards.
Yeah, if I were to kind of push harder
into discard themes, I think this would
be pretty decent.
Um,
still might be good enough as things
stand.
Uh the strafon is just so good. Like um
first of all, he triggers on life lost
by me. So any land that deals damage to
me, he triggers. If I play Imcure in the
same turn, he triggers. Um and then just
like up to four blood tokens a turn is
just so much. Like that that's that's a
crazy amount of value.
Yeah, demonic junker is great. I I I
have that in here and it's it's so good.
I'm honestly surprised this card doesn't
cost more. I feel like this should this
is a staple in so many decks. Like just
an amazing card.
Um but no. Yeah, I definitely have
uh 70 cents I think is worth it for
blood money. Bottlecap blast is also
quite good.
I
I don't know if I'm running too much
graveyard hate right now. I want to run
ra's charm, but it's
more sense than I want to put into a
removal spell. I think
yeah,
if I were to cut a little bit of value
from this deck,
Yeah, these are my pricing cards, which
I think Yeah, all of these are so good.
Um,
refurbish is here. Uh, I had it
somewhere.
Like I I don't think I put it in the
interaction actually. I think I put it
in the
Yeah, there it is.
See, I keep looking at Oni Cold Anvil,
and it just doesn't seem good. I think I
think it's probably good in like a more
aristocraty deck. I could definitely see
it being good there. U I I actually have
three of the one drop artifacts that
exile graveyards. Um the the cheaper
ones. Uh I hate artifact lands. just so
divided on because
in principle they're really good with an
affinity commander but also
60 cents is is a little rough.
Yeah, Strafon. Uh yeah, we we don't care
about the second line of text there. The
first line of text is just really good
for getting a bunch of blood tokens
every turn. Um,
yeah, Blood Money. Yeah, all of these
all these slightly pricier cards.
Condor. Yeah, Condor is funny. I I kind
of went back and forth on that. Arkbound
Condor is the Where is it? Oh, yeah,
it's right here. It's the
four mana flying modular three artifact
enter target creature opponent also gets
minus one to end turn. I think the fact
that it's flying has a decent body and
then I I think that should be able to
ping like a lot of stuff like if I can
play like two or three artifacts a turn
and some turns I will be playing more
because this is kind of a very
tokenheavy deck.
Um
yeah I am I do yeah I do have morbid
curiosity I believe. Um,
I also I want to have Imposing Grandeur
as well, but uh I just think it's
probably worse than just about any other
card I can add for a buck 27. Um, I
actually cut the Brothers War, which is
like kind of a assorted value card, and
Imposing Grandur, which is draw equal to
the commander mana value and then
discard or other order. Um, I cut those
two for Illuminor Saras, which is one of
the ones that can sack a creature to
gain an amount of black equal to the
creature's mana value. Uh, I think
that's worth it. Like, Saras definitely
just dies in some cases, like if if the
opponents are smart and have removal
ready, but if it does survive, it's so
crazy.
Sorry, I have a cat here who wants
attention.
Hey, buddy. You want to say hi?
Okay.
Yeah, Deadly Dispute is one I've been
kind of debating.
That's a definitely a pretty good one.
Um,
yeah.
Yep.
We got
we got Arao in the flesh here.
Um,
let me see if there were maybe board
cards I wanted. Uh, I think so. This
card, have any of you played with this
card? The Nipton lottery. This is one
that like it's a very cheap board wipe
in black red which makes it tempting. Uh
very cheap four mana board wipe I think
is pretty tempting but I don't know how
big that downside is. I think in
principle this deck is a little bit more
aggressive than most. So I think it's
okay. But I'm definitely debating
whether or not this card is worth it.
Dargo seems pretty decent here too.
Dargo,
see, but that's the
Yeah, this deck doesn't actually
sacrifice that many artifacts for having
an artifact sack commander. Like,
it it it has some it has some amount
like uh I could do the math, but
I I actually don't know how much this
deck is going to struggle with life. I
I've put in a little bit of life gain.
Like I've put in Poet's Quill.
I put in anything else. Yeah, I put in
like at least one more. Yeah, Mask of
Grizzlebrand. That's right. So, I put in
a couple options for life gain. Um,
so I think that's enough, but I really
don't know because this this deck
definitely is very much a life-paying
deck.
Deadly Coverup.
What are you doing, bud?
You want to go find that wasp for me?
Uh, a deadly cover up evidence
collected. Exile card from opponent's
graveyard. Then search for
seem seems fine. Um,
seems more aimed at
60 card formats, I think.
True. Ma massacre girl. Massacre girl
does exist.
Yeah, I I was I know there I was hoping
for a better collect evidence thing. I
know that that's probably aimed at the
60 card formats. Um,
maser girl is okay. Yeah, I probably
have enough tokens to enable the maser
maybe. I don't actually know. Um,
but yeah, I might I might at least try
out the tip nipton lottery and see how
that goes because I think that should be
kind of fun. Um,
and then my other my other board wipes
are great. I love Teresa's Devastation
and I love love love Blood Money in this
deck. It's so gross. You just blood
money play out start popping off.
But yeah, I I I I enjoy the Maser Girl.
I remember Maser Roll was a
staple in the first $25 pool. Um
just because like a
what what's usually a board wipe on a 44
Menace stick is just like really solid.
Just a great card. How much How much is
this Maser girl these days? Five bucks.
Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. Cover cover up can just be a
great XL for sure. Just nail it
something. Um
Yeah.
I just like the four mana here,
honestly.
I'll probably try it out.
Um,
wonder if there's any other options for
life gain in black red. So, that that is
an area where I'm a little worried. I
think there are
uh
there's some like leech gauntlet that I
I had considered. Um, there's also like
batter bone, which I think is also
decent,
uh, as just like a, you know, kind of
blocker guy that can turn into a
lifelink.
Maser worm is definitely good. Yeah,
little bit of a different function
though.
Whiff. Yeah, whiff of Veros would be
good if I had more budget. I I I would
love something like that. But that one
that one I think is that that one has
stayed expensive for so long.
I underestimated how good. Yes, it's
it's seven bucks. I guess it it saw a
precon printing, so it's at least gone
down a little bit, but yeah. No, giving
your whole board lifelink in black is
very good. And then
wow, that Yeah, that the second ability
is just also good. Um, which which makes
it for a pretty good package.
All board wipes is a bracket 2 ED.
Bracket one deck. My theme is board
wipes.
Have have fun gamers.
Nighthawk Scavenger is definitely
decent. Um I I run that in my Malfagore
deck actually because that deck is also
fairly hungry for life gain. Um but I
think that deck is also a lot more
amendable to generic. Um,
here I would probably prefer to run.
God, the equip five on Batterbone sucks.
I hate that. That's such a large number.
Um, yeah,
Pose Quill is just the the best budget
lifelink equipment by a long shot. I
think
Golem's Heart. Yeah. What What is the
text on Golem's Heart? I think it's when
you cast an artifact spell.
Whenever a player cast an artifact
spell, you make
um how much life is that could be
gaining? I could see that being pretty
good. I could see that being pretty
good. Yeah, actually though
feel a little weird running pure life
cards, but I mean let's be honest,
Poqu Quill is basically a pure life game
card. Gonna toss that in the maybe board
for now. Decide a little later if I
actually want it.
You can discard for a Oh. Oh, sure.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Let's see what the rate looks like on
that.
Cuz if I It's cycling, right?
Is that one? I guess I I don't I don't
even know if that's the original text.
No, it's not the original text.
That is the alchemy text. Okay.
Oh, right. Carsey Revenant. Carsey
Revenant is decent.
If I had I'll have to see how heavy my
discard package is because my I have a
heavy discard package. I think Carsy
Revenant becomes really decent. Is it
still I It shouldn't be one of you.
No, maybe it is. Damn.
No, that's fair. It's a good card.
Yeah, Carsey is lovely, lovely, lovely.
My mouth deck. Honestly, I feel like
bracket
uh after the three-hour bracket 2 game I
had in Vegas, I think uh bracket 2 needs
to
not have a whole lot of board wipes or
like not have some number of stalling
things cuz wow that that can go along.
Um unbreakable bond is kind of funny.
Metamorphosis fanatic is kind of funny.
Life encounter and nunch. Yeah.
None of these are all that great. I
guess alchemist assistant is a is a
cheaper version of the the carcy
revenant type effect. But I I don't I
still don't think that's all that good
unless I have a lot of discard. So if I
go O discard,
I can try blood after this because blood
blood is way of discarding. Oh, discard.
Um, not really. Not really. No,
no. Yes. Yes. That's two of those plus
the quill. Three
blood.
Seven ways of discarding total, I would
say. So, yeah, that's
it's a little awkward. If I if I get
more discard in here, I think it becomes
pretty decent. But
yeah,
true. Yeah, I I can just play it. Um,
this deck does try to curve out pretty
aggressively, but it it should have
extra mana on like turn
five usually, sometimes earlier if
things aren't going quite to plan.
So, you can just kind of swing in a bit.
Bracket 2 definitely does have a bit of
a winning problem. Um, it's a little bit
tricky.
Oh,
the scryfall filter fo discard for full
full oracle be would be get blood
because it lets you search for oracle
and reminder text and every that's
really good to know. I did not know
that. Oh, discard. Yeah, that'll get me
the quill as well.
Yeah, that's that's super helpful.
Oh, yeah. Yeah, it hits cycling as well,
I guess. Yeah, sure.
That's interesting.
In some cases, hitting cycling might not
be helpful, but that's that's really
good to know.
True. One one with nothing might might
be a little gooded here.
Uh,
Malfore. Let's go. Let's pop off.
Um,
yeah, I'll need to look at my options
for this card. This is a this is a very
cheap ISA aggressive deck. So, um, I was
very happy to see that there was a one
of these effects. Um, walking atlas, I
think. Yeah,
one of those effects that had flying as
well. Like, it's just that that's
lovely.
It's a funny little UFO.
Now, here's Nightblade. Yeah, I have I
have some aristocrat stuff, but I'm I'm
not I I'm currently not opting to go
very hard on Aristocrat stuff for this
deck. Um doing a lot more like beatd
down stuff. Like I think I have like
one, two, three, four, five
six. I have seven cards with power temps
equal to the number of artifacts you
control and then like a doubler and a
couple beatd down guys. Some other stuff
that goes pretty fast. Um, Herald, an
early Herald of Angu, which is gross.
Uh, so I this deck is definitely going
more for a beatdown windcon rather than
aristocrat style thing.
Uh, opinions on EDHB the default new
player format for overall game format
health? Uh, so I wish
I wish more people were getting into
stuff outside of Commander. I think it'd
be cool to see more of an emphasis put
on draft formats. Um, I would love to
see another like conspiracy set. I don't
know if that I I I don't have a sense of
whether that's a draw to newer players,
but I think
kind of more casualish limited formats
would be or seem like a good way to
also get newer players into the game. Um
though, aside from that, it's basically
just arena. I feel like I don't know if
like casual constructed is still a
thing. I I really don't have a sense of
that being an EDH YouTuber who's been
playing the game for like, you know,
a long time, 13 years or something.
Delarium skaines is pretty funny.
Oh, yeah. Scourge familiar. That
it's the one that disc you discard to
get black manor. Yeah, that's that's a
wild card. H I can I can see it though,
honestly. That's that's not a bad
not a bad card. Um because this deck
does get like kind of pretty dramatic
amounts of card advantage. So, I could
definitely see that working out.
I know. I know. Yeah, dra draft is
intimidating. Sealed is intimid or not
sealed. Uh cube is intimidating. I like
to think that sealed is more
a better jumping in point. Um although I
know it can still be overwhelming. Like
there's just naturally going to be some
players who are kind of, you know,
quicker at deck building earlier in
their magic career than others. Um
because I've definitely, you know, I've
seen players where you kind of get them
into the game and they're, you know,
kind of getting it putting it putting
together stuff. It might not be the best
deck, but at least they're like able to
like put together something. Whereas
there are definitely other players who
like it kind of takes them a bit to get
that deck building impulse. So,
Scourge Familiar is not an okay card,
[Laughter]
man. Man, Otter Otter TV, you're still
you're still pushing that for Xium
portal.
Oh, wow.
I I feel like Yeah,
Dice, dude. I feel like jump start is
potentially a really good onboarding
route for newer players. Um, I also feel
like that you can build
I feel like you can build like a
jump start format that is interesting to
older players as well. Like I feel like
there are ways to give a little bit of
kind of curation and uh customization
feel um while still keeping it very
approachable. That's definitely an area
I think it would be cool to explore more
for sure.
Popper.
I don't know if I would say the closest
thing to casual constructed is Popper,
but I also don't have a sense of
how
how wide the brewing is in Popper versus
Standard. I I think it is pretty wide in
Popper. Um in current standard, who
knows? Uh, but
yeah, Pop definitely Popper has a pretty
like fast aggressive metag game. Um,
it's it's still like a very kind of the
decks tend to be pretty simple, so I
think it's still decent in that way.
But but
yeah, I don't know. It definitely
depends on the player. I think EDH is
nice because you can build a deck and
hop into a game without needing to
follow any sort of metag game or be
competitive in any way.
So, I don't know. I
popper popper could be the solution for
some people. I think if they're just
looking for a simple deck and they're
willing to get kind of into the the the
kind of intense deck building aspect of
it, willing to like make a deck that
does some good stuff by turn four
because that really is what you need to
do to survive in Popper is you need to,
you know, be developing stuff fast or,
you know, building up suppression fast.
I don't know.
Do I think I will do another $25 deck
pool? Uh,
stay tuned.
Not going to get too much more into it
than that.
They do jump start cubes, battle boxes,
too. I like the idea of commander jump
start with random partner commanders.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I I wonder
in theory like you could I think if
you're willing to break color
restrictions, there are some cool like
commander cube options. Like if you give
people like a
uh a jump start set where there's like
one default commander, but then you can
there are like a handful of other
legendary creatures within the jump
start pools. I think that that could be
pretty cool. um give you a lot of
options.
Uh so there are definitely option
although I I kind of wonder who
Commander Cube is for. Um
because I know in my ideal world,
Commander Cube would be a way to get
Commander players into Cube. Um
but I think that that might be wishful
thinking on my part.
15 card pioneer. 15 card pioneer
Highlander. That's wild.
That's really funny. Yeah. I I think if
you have a bunch of people with like a
brewer's instinct, uh I think doing some
sort of custom format is super super
cool. Um, and that can be like a really
Yeah, doing Yeah, custom formats can be
so cool if you can like
uh construct them in a way where they're
balanced, but also like the the kind of
possibility space of it isn't too like
the possibility space of it isn't too
tight. Like you can you can or too
figured out. I think there there's a lot
of cool stuff you can do.
Yeah,
Elder Kellen Highlander.
There are a lot of Kellins.
Yeah, Whippos is a really really good
card. So, I I I always wish it wasn't
money, but uh it it it is it is a very
very good card and I understand why.
This conversation also reminds me of Dan
Dan. Yeah, Dan Dan.
I don't know who Dan Dan is for.
That's an interesting format. I don't
know.
Uh, I think in principle it makes for a
good
I I like the idea of it. Like I like the
idea of using cards in creative ways,
like in a shared deck. Um, I think
that's that's the sort of thing that uh
makes for some cool custom formats is
kind of breaking out cards into new or
different use cases. Um,
I think the blue Dandan list in
particular doesn't really appeal to me
personally, but uh I think in principle
it could be cool.
So there there is
Jack Pups and bird. That's hilarious.
Uh,
they're definitely red versions of Dan
Dan. I don't remember what the core card
is.
Uh,
red dandan.
Sure. I'll click on this top Moxfield
deck called Red Dan Dan
Craig. Sorry.
Oh, that's so good. Oh, no.
I love it.
Oh Lord,
what on earth?
We got like a bunch of ping. Little bit
of ping.
Shake. Yeah, shake the foundations. It's
got to be crazy here.
Wow.
Um, so how auto include is whip of
Arabos?
Uh,
I so, so I think, uh, I like to keep my
budget decks pretty budget generally. um
like like both for for like obviously I
don't need to buy cards for a reason,
but also just keep the list that way
even if I have access to more expensive
cards. Um
that is
partially because I'm a YouTuber and if
I have public decks, it's nice if they
are budget. You know, if people stroll
over to my Malfagore deck and they see
it's like a, you know, $100 deck or
whatever, that's a lot better than if
they stroll over to it and see it's a
$200 deck or something. Um, so I like
that aspect of it. And then also just
like for some decks I find it better to
put a budget cap on it. Specifically,
budget works as a kind of standin for
power in some ways. Not not in all ways,
but in some ways. Um, that's kind of
what I do with my rata deck is, you
know, keeping out the expensive cards
keeps out some amount of stuff that I
wouldn't find as interesting. So,
I think that's that's another reason to
run uh budget stuff for me at least.
Um unrelated, but if I run Possibility
Storm and Unrelated, but if I run
Possibility Storm in all my red decks,
am I a bad person?
Uh see, I feel like Possibility Storm is
like a chaos card that feels like a
stacks piece.
Uh, right. Like that that it's like one
of the most staxy chaos cards. I don't
know. It's it's funny.
I definitely wouldn't run it in every
deck, but
I think Possibility Storm is more
justifiable to me than something like
Warp World um or something similar like
that.
Yeah, Whip of Arabos. I specifically
definitely have some nostalgia for
because uh
I my original commander deck was mono
black built during born of the gods. So
uh I I was I was hype on that whip of
Arabos. I was hype on that Arabos. I was
you know enjoying all sorts of that
stuff.
Yeah. pro proxy everything is, you know,
that's that's a that's a valid move. Um,
I definitely think being open to
proxying is good and I I probably I'm
probably going to try and build a cube
at some point later this year and I'll
definitely proxy that because
buying that is expensive if you're
running kind of nice cards. But
yeah, I don't know. I usually buy paper
cards for my decks just because it's
I don't really have a reason. I just
kind of like having them in paper.
Commander costs at most 10 rails without
the commander. That is like $2. Wow.
That's wild.
I respect it though. That's that's
that's kind of fun.
Proxing your
booger blue players.
Proxy is definitely great for testing a
deck. Um,
yeah, it's it's just nice in general if
you don't want to like have a
collection. Um, cuz like there are times
when it's like, okay, I pull a card,
I'll see if I need it for a deck later,
that can be kind of nice because you can
just put put together decks on the fly.
Um, but if you're not having a
collection, not having like a major
group of cards, then
yeah, proxying works just fine.
FX. Okay, I will say Fxyian Portal did
not fit in either of these decks. It
does not make sense in either place.
However, that's a really funny card. So,
I I might try and find a deck for it at
some point.
I I do enjoy because it is just like a
decent colorless value engine. I mean,
it exiles your deck pretty fast, I
think, because it you exile
Yeah, theoretically can exile your deck
pretty fast, but it's still pretty
funny.
Yeah.
All right. Well, I think I am kind of
done with my deck building for the
morning. Uh, so I am probably going to
sign off here, but uh I will most likely
be streaming either tomorrow or the day
after doing some MTGO gameplay. Uh, so
that that should be kind of fun to
get some standard gameplay happening.
Maybe Vintage Cube. We'll see.
I've considered adding a color Dorado,
but I just I don't I I don't feel like
bothering really. You know, I I like the
deck in green red. I think if I was
trying to build like the best possible
version of that deck, I might add a
color, but I'm really not. I think that
the deck as it is works pretty good.
I feel like we've done some chat about
custom formats on Magic Mirror. I think
it was on the episode
uh in December
that went with my video about uh
what EDH only players miss. So, if you
check out the a December episode, I
think we did a fair amount of custom
format discussion there. I might even be
able to link it. Let me see.
Hello. Hello and welcome to the Magic
Mirror podcast. I'm your host Khan the
Trinket Mage and with me is my co-host
33 Elk. Hi Elk.
Let me see what players miss out on.
Yeah. Yeah, this this is the one.
I'll drop a I'll drop a link to that.
Yeah,
that's that's a good discussion of
custom formats. Um, all right, with that
I am headed out.
Lovely to have you all here with me.